nice lul weh größer keck weh muss einfach noch mal gesagt werden
ne mir ist gerade nichts bescheuertes eingefallen zum start eigentlich ist mir
gar nichts zum start eingefallen ich habe irgendwas gesagt aber so wie
man das hier macht auf twitch fehlt einfach irgendein schwachsinn und die
leute gucken einem glücklicherweise bei zu leute ich sehe gerade ich habe 18.000
follower geknackt auf twitch das ist ja warum ist denn der sound so laut
ich habe auf 50 prozent gestellt das fail sagt kann sich wieder nicht
entscheiden jetzt wieder lautstärke ist nein das stimmt nicht genau umgedreht
nicht so nah ist übrigens gestern im stream geguckt und da hat einer eine
wirklich exzellente frage gestellt und zwar warum gibt es
lul
nur pepega als emote warum gibt es nicht paypega für irgendwelchen pay to win geschichten das
müsste es doch eigentlich auch geben dass da noch keiner auf die idee gekommen
ist paypega als emote zu machen das sollte man es gibt es gibt ja das
pepega ding mit kreditkarte warum warum heißt das nicht paypega eher fragen
fragen über fall windows paypega ist zum beispiel windows 11 ist paypega ich
mache einfach den windows ich mach einfach das windows mo会
es rein bei mir entscheiden das heißt dann wo pepe 0 0 0 0 0 übrigens ich habe ich habe die
woche bis in news gelesen bei golem und golem hat mich hart getriggert hier was habe ich da
gerade gelesen windows 2021 kostet ja das ist mir sowas von egal gibt es wirklich jemand der windows
2000 also der der der ordentliche office nicht weil der office freiwillig verwendet ja ich weiß
diese ganze sekretärin in dieser welt verwenden office 2021 aber wer ist wer ist wirklich noch
wer befindet sich also wer benutzt das wirklich freiwillig ich also generell für mich haben office
office sweeten also office produkt keine daseinsberechtigung das einzige die einzige
wisst ihr was die einzige anwendung ist wo ich verstehe dass man die verwendet wo ich auch einen
gewissen mehrwert drin sehe die einzige anwendung aus office
ist aber so one note zähle ich nicht zu office und outlook ist ja auch im prinzip was eigenes die
einzige anwendung ist excel excel ist die einzige anwendung die irgendwie daseinsberechtigung hat
excel ist die programmierumgebung der sekretärin in dieser welt oder sekretäre sekretärinnen
müssten wir heutzutage sagen wenn man da ganz korrekt ist darix moin
sekunde ich muss mal kurz mein nasen putzen ich glaube das wollt ihr nicht mit mikrofon anmachen
wollt ihr nicht also was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ich wollte mich ja gar nicht so sehr über
office corona zeit ein wieder hier jetzt aber jetzt aber ich wollte mich ja eigentlich gar
nicht über office aufregen ja wir benutzen auch noch office was sollen sie sonst nutzen kein kein
gar kein office office ist komplett operate du brauchst eigentlich office für nix ich schreibe
kommentar und formate also am ende export als html ohne dass ich dafür irgendwelchen office
verwendet übrigens also was ich wollte wollte mich gar nicht so aufregt golam hat mich übelst
getriggert sie woche und zwar die haben irgendwas geschrieben zu new world ab hier die haben
geschrieben als ich diese überschrift als ich diese überschrift gelesen habt habe ich mich
mega aufgeregt also für meine verhältnisse mega aufgeregt da sie ist also eigentlich eigentlich
ist bis nach wie vor egal aber ich hatte mich aufgelegt dass sie sowas geschrieben haben die
New World zerstört jetzt nicht nur GeForce, das ist einfach kompletter Schwachsinn.
Das ist, jetzt fangen die mit diesem Mist auch schon an, das ist kompletter Schwachsinn.
New World zerstört keine Grafikkarten.
Die Hersteller bauen minderwertige Hardware, das liegt doch nicht an New World.
Was soll das, was soll dieser Blödsinn?
Spielst du den New World Wartenschlang-Simulator?
Nein, ich spiele New World gar nicht.
Und in drei Monaten werden sich die Leute zu...
Ich sag's euch jetzt, wie es ist mit New World.
In drei Monaten werden sich die Leute zurücksehnen, nach der Zeit, wo sie in Warteschlangen gesessen haben.
Weil die Server haben bloß 2000 Spieler und in drei, vier Monaten sind 60, 70 Prozent der Spieler weg.
Was bleiben wird bei New World, da bin ich relativ sicher, sind halt die Leute, die das Gilden-Faction-basierte PvP mögen.
Aber das sind die meisten Leute, die spielen nicht.
Die wissen es bloß doch nicht.
Werden wir sehen, werden wir sehen.
Also, ich...
Ich tippe da ganz stark drauf.
Mal gucken, vielleicht liege ich auch komplett falsch.
Aber ich habe da ein ganz gutes Gefühl für mittlerweile.
Normalerweise.
So, was die hier für einen Stoß schreiben, ist totaler Blödsinn.
New World zerstört keine Grafikkarten.
Was sich ja auch rausgestellt hat in der Alpha ist, dass die Leute in der Warteschlange gehängt haben, dass dort...
Spooky-Spoda-Musik, ja.
Dass dort die FPS nicht gecappt waren und deswegen die Grafikkarten überhitzt sind.
Das liegt aber am System, am Aufbau, beziehungsweise an den schlechten...
Äh, an der schlechten Qualität der Grafikkarte.
Das, das war's.
Das New World macht das nicht kaputt.
Okay, Nachtrag.
Oh Mann.
Die schreiben wirklich...
Die bleiben da wirklich bei.
By the way, wenn ich diese Sache hier sehe...
New World, der New World-Grafik-Style.
Das ist eines der...
Okay, wie umschreibe ich das jetzt am besten?
Mir fällt da kein richtiges Wort für ein...
So, am meisten gewollt und nicht gekonnt, den ich in letzter Zeit in so einem AAA-Game gesehen habe.
Der ist es nicht.
Der ist nicht wirklich schlecht.
Also, du merkst schon, dass die Leute...
Ich weiß jetzt, wie es aussieht.
Ich weiß, wie der New World...
Jetzt fällt es mir ein.
Der New World-Grafik-Style sieht ein bisschen so aus, als hat jemand sich fünf verschiedene Asset-Packs gekauft,
die ungefähr thematisch in die gleiche Richtung gehen,
hat aber Mittelalter...
Äh, Mittelalter und Piraten-Settings gemischt dabei.
Das so sieht New World aus, als hätten sie fünf verschiedene Asset-Packs gekauft,
die ungefähr in die gleiche Richtung gehen und ins gleiche Game gepackt.
Weil die haben das selbst gemacht, aber es sieht einfach so echt so unpassend aus.
So...
Das hier, das hier, das hier...
Okay.
Ne?
Das sieht irgendwie noch nach Mittelalter aus.
Das sieht nach, ich weiß es nicht, aus, äh...
Schnellwittchen und die sieben Zwerge, keine Ahnung.
Und das sieht so ein bisschen eher so nach, keine Ahnung, Pirate-Kolonialzeit, wie auch immer,
aus.
Das ist...
Ah!
Das, das schmerzt mir immer so richtig, wenn ich New World Gameplay sehe,
dass das so unpasst, dass sie zusammen...
Die Zauberanimation, ja gut, das stimmt, aber das finde ich auch, äh, legitim,
ähm, weil in New World ist teilweise relativ viel los, Open World, PvP-Technisch,
und wenn da alle Zauber super krasse Animationen hätten,
würde sie gar nicht mehr durchblicken.
Aber es ist einfach, es ist einfach Schwachsinn, dass New World...
Aber guck mal, was sagt denn die Kommentare, was sagen denn die Kommentare dazu?
Das, okay, das Forum war jetzt...
Bescheid, das Forum war jetzt bescheid.
Also, was sagt das Forum?
Guck mal hier, drei Seiten Thread.
Natürlich, egal was ein Spiel macht, darf die Grafikkarte werden, das...
Ja, natürlich, da hat er recht.
Richtig.
Na, genau so ist es, genau so ist es.
Wenn du...
Wenn du als Hersteller, und das ist ja nicht so, als würde New World da irgendwelche speziellen Dinger machen,
gehen wir mal von aus.
Wenn du als, wenn du als Hersteller die Schnittstellen verwendest, die dir die Hersteller anbieten,
was im Endeffekt...
Irgendwas ist von DirectX bis Vulkan bis meinetwegen, oh, GL, was auch immer.
Was hab ich, aus Mental geworden?
Mental ist jetzt, glaube ich, in Vulkan mit drin, ne?
Na, egal.
Und dann, dann kannst du die Grafikkarte nicht kaputt machen.
Es sei denn, der Hersteller hat's verschissen und das ist in diesem Fall so.
Naja.
Das hat mich wirklich hart, hart getriggert, als ich das gelesen hab.
Echt?
Da kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Stand das in der Alpha auch da?
Das ist aber so eine richtige Kokona-Warnung.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr daran erinnern.
Ich kann mich noch an meine alte Microsoft, Microsoft Office Keyboard.
Ich hatte, ich hatte mal so einen richtig pettes, sowas hier in der Richtung.
Das da, nur in schwarz.
Office Keyboard.
Das hatte ich früher mal nur in schwarz.
So, das hier.
Genau das, genau das.
Das war eines der ersten USB-Tastaturen, die es gegeben hat.
Und wenn, wenn man das umgedreht hat, diese Tastatur, übrigens, die fand ich richtig cool, die Tastatur.
Also, die, die, die hab ich, die hatte ich, guck mal, es kostet nicht viel.
Die, die hatte ich bestimmt zehn Jahre lang oder so.
Die fand ich richtig geil.
Auch, auch, das war auch, ich fand's auch relativ ökonomisch mit dieser Handauflage.
Leider war das so eine ganz normale Billigtastatur drunter, die, die, die nach ein paar Jahren so krass gewobbelt hat,
dass du, also hier auf so einer halbmechanischen kannst du wirklich schnell spammen.
Das ging auf, das ging, das ging auf der gar nicht richtig.
Hm, du hast da teilweise 150 Millisekunden Tastendruck und sowas.
Naja, zumindest hinten drauf auf dieser Tastatur,
auf dieser Tastatur,
stand so der typische, der typische Kokona-Hinweis,
das Verwenden, also Achtung, das Verwenden einer Tastatur kann zu schweren gesundheitlichen Schäden führen.
Das ist halt so die typische, die typische Kokona-Anweisung.
Wie auch immer, also, das, das ist so eine typische Ami-Anweisung,
weil wenn man die Tastatur nimmt und damit andere Leute quasi irgendwie auf den Kopf schlägt,
dann, dann kann die zu schweren Gesundheitsschäden führen.
Wenn man eine Tastatur zudem verwendet, wie sie da ist, an den Rechner angeschlossen zu werden und zu tippen,
dann wird es schwierig mit schweren gesundheitlichen Schäden.
Aber bei den Amis ist das alles möglich.
Ich meine, bei den Amis weißt du nie, vielleicht nehmen die die auch mit auf irgendeine Shooting Range,
wie heißt das, Shooting Range, Firing Range, was auch immer,
und versuchen, und gucken, ob man durchschießen kann und stellen sich dabei dahinter
und lassen sich dann erschießen oder so und sagen, oh, ich dachte, die Tastatur blockt das.
Also, bei den Amis bin ich mir da bei nix, da halte ich alles für möglich.
Die kriegen das irgendwie hin, ja.
Ja gut, die schlagen halt einfach ihren Kopf drauf.
Ach, was auch immer, das ist totaler Blödsinn.
Hey Max, ich will später einmal Softwareentwickler werden.
Excellent, excellent.
Also, haben mich bei mehreren Ausbildungen beworben,
bei der Fachinformatiker-Anwendungsentwicklung leider nur Absagen.
Haben die gesagt, warum?
Oder war da nur diese übliche Geschichte,
äh, viel, viel Glück auf ihrem,
auf ihrem weiteren Weg, so.
Bei der Fachinformatiker-Systemintegration eine Zusage,
sind die beiden aus, nein, die sind nicht,
also es kommt auf den Betrieb an, von der Berufsschule und von der Prüfung
sind die nicht großartig unterschiedlich.
Im Betrieb wird es schon ziemlich unterschiedlich sein,
was du machst, je nach Betrieb.
Wohnt es sich dann überhaupt, eine Fachinformatiker-Systemintegration-Ausbildung zu machen,
oder soll ich, lieber bis nächstes Jahr,
also ich würde, also wenn ich eine Zusage hätte,
also, ich würde es von zwei Dingen abmachen.
Taugt der Betrieb, den ich hier, äh, wo eine Zusage habe,
also wenn der, wenn dir der Betrieb,
also wenn du jetzt eine Zusage hast,
und du nicht sagst, Alter, so ein Kackler, da will ich auf gar keinen Fall hin,
dann würde ich die Ausbildung machen.
Ich würde, also würde ich die Ausbildung anfangen.
Die müsste, die müsste doch jetzt auch losgehen.
Die hätte doch jetzt eigentlich anfangen müssen,
wann soll die denn losgehen?
Was ist, ist denen,
ist denen ein Azubi vielleicht abgesprungen,
denen hier, weil normalerweise
haben die alle schon angefangen.
Oder, oder ist das eine Ausbildung für 2022
jetzt schon?
Das müsstest du mal schreiben.
Zumindest, also ich, also wenn ich den Betrieb
einigermaßen okay finden würde, würde ich
da anfangen, denn man muss sagen, in der Berufsschule
als auch von der Prüfung ist es nicht so ein großer
und eigentlich gar kein, also ein minimaler
Unterschied. Ja, du hast in der Abschlussprüfung
ein bisschen, du hast ein Teil, ist
ein bisschen unterschiedlich, für Anwendungsentwickler
Systemintegration, und auch in der
Berufsschule ist es nicht so ein wahnsinniger Unterschied.
Du, du hast die Lernfelder ein bisschen anders
gewichtet, aber im Prinzip ist es der gleiche Shit.
So.
Und
nichtsdestotrotz kannst du, nachdem
du eine Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
Ausbildung gemacht hast, äh, wenn du,
wenn du gut programmieren kannst, oder wenn du dich
in irgendeinem Bereich auskennst, den man braucht,
äh, für, bei, bei, bei
Softwareentwicklung, kannst du das auch ohne Probleme
später machen. Das meiste lernt man ja
eh nicht in der Ausbildung, wenn es rein um
sagen wir so Programmiergrundlagen geht,
zumindest ich, also ich konnte, ich, wie gesagt,
ich konnte schon lange vor meiner Ausbildung programmieren,
und
die Kombination aus beidem
hat es im Endeffekt auch dazu geführt, dass ich das mache,
was ich mache, ja. Also, ich hab,
ich hab bei einem Provider Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration gelernt, ich hab
mich schon immer für Softwareentwicklung Programmieren
interessiert, und im Endeffekt bin ich
deswegen auch so in diese DevOps-Schiene reingerutscht,
und leider mache ich heutzutage quasi
die Hälfte meiner Zeit irgendwelche sinnlosen Code-Reviews,
aber ich kann in letzter Zeit ja glücklicherweise auch wieder
mehr programmieren selbst.
Tja.
Aber, das
eine oder das andere, das
zementiert nicht deinem, für
immer deinen beruflichen Weg, so.
Holstack
Dev bis Sack of Ops, genau.
So sieht's aus, so sieht's aus.
Und Agile.
Agile, Agile musst du sein.
Massive Agile.
So, mal gucken, ob er jetzt drauf geantwortet hat.
Nope.
M-X-X-A-R-X
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht, aber danke für den Prime-Sub.
Huge Subscription.
Nice.
Ah ja.
So, ich hab ein Problem,
Leute, mein Browser war der Meinung,
beziehungsweise mein YouTube war der Meinung,
es hat alle
Cookies vergessen und
immer, wenn ich Google aufmache,
bekomme ich jetzt sinnlose, random
allgemeine Empfehlungen. Warum ich hier
halbwegs sinnvolle Empfehlungen krieg,
liegt daran, weil ich vorhin schon mal ein paar
Videos aufgemacht hab, die wir letzte Woche
geguckt haben und danach noch ein paar andere Videos
aufgemacht hab, dass es so ungefähr
wieder halbwegs matcht, was die uns
empfehlen sollen. Nur eine
Sache irritiert mich bei
YouTube, das krieg ich auch auf meinem
Alter, ich hab noch irgendwas.
Irgendwas im
Hals.
Ich krieg auch auf meinem normalen
YouTube mittlerweile relativ
viel Weeb-Zeug
empfohlen. Ich weiß nicht
genau warum, ich guck eigentlich
so gut wie nix an Anime oder sonst
was und mittlerweile ist
also Weeb Nation
ist auf YouTube hier angesagt.
Guck mal, ich krieg sogar Videos hier empfohlen
von irgendwelchen
von irgendwelchen Battlefield-Videos.
Ich wusste bis jetzt nicht
mal, dass es Battlefields
VTuber gibt.
Es gibt Battlefield VTuber.
Kann man sich das denn vorstellen?
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Naja.
Ich hab vier oder fünf Videos gebuckt, aber vieles davon
ist nicht IT.
In welche Richtung das geht, wir gucken ja nicht nur IT-Stells.
Oh, YouTube noch eine
Chance. Mein Bein juckt.
Warum juckt mein Bein?
Hm. Na gut, wäre
besser, als wenn's nichts mehr macht, ne? Also wenn's nicht juckt, wäre auch nicht gut.
Also wenn's nicht juckt, wäre auch nicht gut.
Ja, genau.
Ich glaub, das ist das beste Aufwachprogramm.
Ich glaub, das ist das beste Aufwachprogramm. Wir gucken uns
einen zwei Stunden Docker-Kurs an. Easy.
Dann seid ihr bestimmt
dann seid ihr bestimmt alle wahnsinnig wach danach.
Vergessen, den Inkognito-Modus auszumachen.
Ist nicht Inkognito-Modus.
Aber 1,5 Millionen Views.
Ey, die machen ganz gute Videos.
Die machen ganz gute Videos. Also ich kann das verstehen.
Und Docker ist ja nach wie vor eines der gefragtesten Sachen.
Gerade weil es auf jeden Fall von Vorteil ist, sei es, wenn man jetzt in Richtung irgendwie, wie heißt das neue CoreOS?
Flatcar heißt es jetzt, glaube ich.
Oder irgendwelche Containerbetriebssysteme geht oder sei es irgendwelche Kubernetes-Geschichten.
Da ist es Docker-Vorkenntnisse auf jeden Fall äußerst praktisch.
Ich finde es, by the way, ich finde es immer noch die schlechteste Benahmung.
Ups.
GitHub Flatcar.
Ich finde es immer noch die schlechteste Produktbenahmung aller Zeiten, Alter.
FlatcarLinux.
Das klingt so, so nichtssagend und CoreOS hat irgendwie noch Sinn ergeben, ja?
Ich meine, es ist flach, ich verstehe schon, dünn und so, aber das ist so dumm, die Benahmung einfach nur.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich kann damit nichts anfangen.
So.
Also, YouTube schafft es nicht, uns sinnvolle Sachen zu empfehlen.
Deswegen lassen wir uns jetzt eine Runde von Levelcaptchibaben, würde ich sagen.
Was richtig heißt, ist Döcker.
Warum nicht?
Döcker.
Döcker, das hört sich fast an, wirklich wie irgendein türkisches, wie irgendein türkischer Nachtisch oder so.
Hast du heute schon Döcker gegessen?
Döcker mit allem, wie immer.
Ne, ich finde, das hört sich irgendwie wie Nachtisch an.
Schon Döcker gemacht.
Do you really find...
Stack-Overflow-Stells.
Ne, nicht Stack-Overflow, Live-Overflow.
Wir kommen ja auf Stack-Overflow.
Ja, Overflow war richtig.
Oh, das ist, das ist, glaube ich, das ist, glaube ich, Big-Brain-Content.
Der ist zu High-IQ für jetzt gleich zum Einstieg.
Was ist das?
Ah.
Ja, ich finde, das hört sich wirklich ähnlich an.
Ich habe immer noch was im Hals.
Ich weiß auch nicht, woran das liegt.
Okay, aber ich hatte auch vor zwei Wochen richtig Halsweh.
Ist aber schon wieder besser.
So, wir lassen uns jetzt eine Runde.
Der Chat wieder.
Wir lassen uns jetzt eine...
Free-Programs, that every PC should have.
Okay.
Ich, ich gib da schnell drüber.
Wir gucken uns jetzt nicht 19 Minuten an.
Ich wette mit euch, das meiste braucht kein Mensch.
Diese Videos, diese Videos sind immer so, so richtig, so richtig...
Jebaited.
Sind diese Videos.
So richtig...
Also, schauen wir mal.
Ah, okay.
Wir haben noch nicht mal Timestamps.
Okay.
Fuck, was ist...
Okay, wir skippen das jetzt.
Wir skippen das jetzt vor.
Was braucht man?
Werbung.
Okay, wo geht's los?
Hier geht's los.
Hä?
Äh...
Umfg.
Huge Hacks.
Okay.
Ach so.
Ja.
Das kenn ich.
Man kann, man kann das verschieben, wenn man öfters klickt.
What I like to get out of this is...
...we can do is...
Hallo, das ist kein Free-Programm, Windows Update ist dabei.
GPU-Z, GPU-Z brauchen 99% der User schon mal nicht.
Es mag ganz praktisch sein, wenn man irgendwelche Hardware öfters ausprobiert,
übertaktet nachgucken will, 99% der User braucht garantiert nicht GPU-Z.
Oder GPU-Z wahrscheinlich, Z, Z, sowas wie Dates.
Vielleicht ist es auch GPUs.
Okay, brauchen wir nicht.
Next, next.
Sind wir noch dabei?
Ey, das ist wirklich praktisch, da hat er recht.
Das ist wirklich praktisch.
Aber wahrscheinlich wollen sich das 99% der User auch nicht angucken.
Das ist aber wirklich praktisch.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern, wo wir unsere eigene GPU-Temperatur-Overlay programmiert haben?
Ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ich glaube, dafür haben wir die CPU-ID oder
HW-Monitor-Library verwendet, die Native Windows HW-Monitor-Library.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube, die haben auch.
Ich glaube, die haben auch eine Library, dass man den Kram abfragen kann aus seinem eigenen Kram, aus seinem eigenen Programm.
Wir haben mal, wir haben mal so einen CPU-GPU-Temperatur-Overlay gebastelt.
Nicht, weil man das braucht, sondern einfach, weil ich wissen wollte, wie das funktioniert.
Ja, okay.
Das ist tatsächlich äußerst praktisch.
Okay, next.
Schon wieder.
Ja.
Okay.
Das brauchen die meisten Leute auch nicht.
Was haben wir ansonsten noch zu bieten?
Das ist wirklich praktisch.
Afterburner ist tatsächlich richtig praktisch.
Das finde ich hat das beste Overlay.
Das beste Overlay, also mittlerweile benutze ich nur das eingebaute Nvidia.
Aber das hat mit, finde ich, mit das beste
Overlay, wenn man wirklich wissen will, ingame, was
abgeht mit seiner Hardware.
Das finde ich wirklich praktisch.
Und auch wenn man Übertaktungsstells macht, ist
Afterburner wirklich nice. Ja, da
würde ich ihm recht geben. Aber, sag mal, das ist wieder so ein Programm,
was 90% der Leute nicht brauchen.
So, next. Oh, fuck,
das gibt's noch. Das verwenden noch Leute.
Krasser Shit. Wusste ich gar nicht.
Orange. It's up in the top left corner.
You can change.
You have that button.
Okay, das war jetzt.
Das war jetzt, aber, also,
wie soll ich sagen?
Also, 20,
20 Minuten Video für drei Programme, die
im Prinzip 99% der
User auf dem Desktop nicht brauchen.
Das ist eher für die
Overclocker-Fraktion.
Ja, das kann man sich auf jeden Fall
darüber streiten, ob das wirklich
jeder braucht.
Warum möchte mir das immer,
warum möchte mir YouTube ein Video empfehlen?
Users 12 Frack Rounds.
Allein schon das, ob ich das gucken soll, ist schon mal
sehr fraglich bei dieser Kombination.
Aber dann von, von, von neun Jahren.
Ah, Kokona Video.
Excellent. Was ist, was bin ich
hier sehen? Welcome to America.
Moment, das ist ein Reaction-Video.
Bedeutet das, wenn wir
das gucken, reacten wir auf
Reaction-Videos? Oder, ne, das machen wir nicht.
Alter,
die sehen aber auch schon mal alle krass,
Kokona aus, oder?
Alter, die sind, die sind ja,
die sind ja in Begriff von Kokona
hier.
Der nicht auf Twitch gesperrt, wer ist das überhaupt?
Was?
Alter, die Amis.
Die Amis, Alter. Richtig
Pfeifert-Content wieder.
Oh Mann. Naja.
Gut. Nachdem YouTube
es nicht schafft, irgendwelche sinnvollen Videos zu
empfehlen, weil YouTube meine Cookies vergessen hat.
Was macht Corona?
Okay, nix, was ich gucken will.
Next.
Ich hab den Impfausweis im Auto.
Dann ist's okay. Was darf's denn sein?
Hab ich mir auch gedacht. Es ist genau das
eingetreten, was ich gesagt hab.
Die ganzen Geschäfte haben
überhaupt gar kein Interesse dran,
das irgendwie zu kontrollieren.
New iPhone, new Anti-Repair-Tactics.
Anti-Repair-Tactics.
Okay, das
gucken wir uns jetzt an. Weil ich
wollte mir ein neues iPhone kaufen, am Ende des
Jahres. Allerdings kein 13er, sondern noch
ein 11er. Und auch nicht für mich.
Jetzt, jetzt.
Wollten sie es aber wissen.
Huge.
Der, der Huge Jeffrey ist das.
Hey Leute, willkommen zurück zu einem
Hugh Jeffreys Video. In diesem Video werden wir
die Repair-Fähigkeit des iPhone 13
beurteilen. Letztes Jahr hatte das iPhone 12
ein paar Software-basierte Locks, die
die Repair-Fähigkeit der 3. Partie
verhindert haben.
Also, was mich am meisten geschockt hat,
bei, ähm, was ich mal gesehen hab in einem
Video, wenn's da drum ging, was Apple gegen
Repair macht. Wenn du ein original iPhone-Display,
oder war's ein Display? Ich glaub, das war ein Display.
Wenn du, wenn du das Display tauscht von
einem Original-iPhone zu einem anderen
Original-iPhone, also wenn du quasi die Base
von einem, von einem iPhone nimmst und das
Display von einem anderen iPhone und pappst
das zusammen, dann bootet es zwar, aber mit
deaktivierten Funktionen. Also, die machen
irgendeine Art und Weise von, ähm,
Handshake, was auch immer, zwischen Display
und, und Mainboard. Obwohl es das Original ist,
geht da nicht alles.
Es ist ein Jahr her, seit der Ausruf von
Hunderttausenden von Leuten über das
Software-Lock von iPhone 12, das die
Repair-Fähigkeit beeinflusst hat. Also, hat
Apple irgendwas verändert? Nein, die haben
das auch schlimmer gemacht. Um die
Repair-Fähigkeit von Apple zu testen,
habe ich zwei iPhone 13 Pro gekauft.
Also, ich glaube, ich glaube, das Letzte,
wovon wir ausgehen, ist, dass Apple irgendwas
daran geändert hat.
Das wird mir ermöglichen, genügend
Apple-Teile zwischen den beiden Geräten
zu unterscheiden. Von außen sehen diese
Smartphones fast identisch aus.
In der Box findet man die gleichen
Accessories wie bei der 12-Serie, die
natürlich ohne Charger oder Headphones
enthalten ist. Es sollte bemerkt werden,
dass die USB-C-Style...
Ernsthaft?
Es ist keine, es ist kein Ladegerät
und keine Kopfhörer mehr beim 12er
dabei? Wirklich nicht?
Ich habe, wie gesagt, ich habe
Anfang des Jahres ein 11er ausgepackt
und da war das noch dabei.
Ich meine, der Scheiß kostet wie viel?
In ordentlicher Ausstattung 1200 Euro?
Für den Preis kann man nicht erwarten,
dass da irgendwie ein Ladegerät
oder ein Kopfhörer dabei ist, ne?
Das ist Apple...
Ach, Gott.
Na gut, da sparen sie halt 5 Euro.
Für die Umwelt?
Jaja, Apple, das habt ihr euch schön...
Also, die Aussage von Apple ist ja
nur wirklich krass jebaited.
Als wäre das für die Umwelt.
Don't plug in to your old
Apple-Telefone.
Also, ich glaube,
das ist ein Ladegerät
mit USB-Type-A-Konnektion.
Das ist für
Tim Cooks Konto
ist das. Wobei man ja sagen muss,
das habe ich letztens irgendwo gelesen,
dass Tim Cook gar nicht so viel Jahresgehalt
bekommt wie andere Top-Manager,
aber der hat jetzt irgendeine
Aktienpaket-Auszahlung bekommen,
weil er eine Weile dabei ist
und das ist irgendwie auch auf einen Schlag
gerade 80 Millionen wert gewesen oder sowas.
Also, am Hungertuch
nagt Tim Apple nun auch nicht, ja?
So, you may have to go out
and buy a new power adapter anyway.
With the blue phone out of the box
90% der Käufer haben ja auch schon
als, nein, es ist nicht sinnvoll.
Bei einem Gerät für 1200 Euro
sollte man das so liefern,
dass man es verwenden kann,
ohne Zusatzgeräte zu kaufen.
It's time to get the gold one out
and remove that paper film
over the display.
Before we take apart these phones,
I pull them up to make sure
they're both fully functional.
Ja, da hätte ich jetzt auch mit gerechnet,
wenn man die auspackt, dass die
beide fully functional sind.
Navigating into settings,
I can pull up the about page.
Both of these phones are iPhone 13 Pros
running iOS 15.
Genau, und weil ja auch gerade
nicht reparierbare Geräte so umweltfreundlich sind.
Also, wenn Apple was von Umweltschutz erzählt,
dann ist das, generell muss man sagen,
es ist aktuell im Trend, umweltfreundlich zu tun,
ohne umweltfreundlich zu sein.
Ich hab irgendwie,
ich hab übelst, übelst Frosch im Hals heute.
Okay, besser.
Ist oft Greenwashing, ja, ist fast alles Greenwashing.
Leute, ich bekomme,
ich bekomme neuerdings Twitter-Werbung
von irgendeinem Mineral,
nee, nicht Mineral,
von irgendeinem Ölkonzern
oder sowas, die auch erzählen,
wir setzen uns für erneuerbare, nachhaltige
Bla, bla, bla, bla.
Ihr habt, ihr habt einfach entdeckt,
dass sich das aktuell gut verkaufen lässt.
Das sind genauso, wie wenn
dann irgendwelche Bierhersteller um die Ecke kommen,
so, für jede verkaufte Flasche
pflanzen wir einen Baum
und solche Geschichten.
Das ist einfach nur, weil die gemerkt haben,
das kommt jetzt gut an.
Das ist nicht, um wirklich was für die Umwelt zu machen.
Am, am,
das ist, das ist tatsächlich so.
Am meisten, ohne Scheiß, am meisten würde es
bringen, sich nicht laufend sinnvoll, äh, sinnlose Sachen
zu kaufen und vor allem nicht so viel,
äh, Plastik ins, ins Meer zu pumpen.
Aber, was heißt, wir pumpen das
Plastik nicht ins Meer, aber es gibt ja
komplett, es gibt ja Satellitenbilder,
da siehst du aus dem Weltall Plastikteppiche
auf dem Meer, die irgendwie so
groß wie, was weiß ich, wie Deutschland oder Hessen,
glaub ich, so groß wie Hessen sind, das ist schon, das ist schon heftig.
Und, ähm, die machen das alle nicht
für die Umwelt. Aber, was man daran sieht, ist,
ähm, das ist, das ist auch ein gutes, das ist,
das ist eigentlich ein ganz gutes Beispiel.
Die Hersteller machen
das nicht für die Umwelt. Die Hersteller machen das, weil
es sich gut verkaufen lässt, für die, für die
eigene Tasche. Aber,
daran, dass, dass das möglich ist,
dass man quasi sagen kann, man ist
umweltfreundlich und die Leute kaufen deswegen
Sachen, dann sieht man, dass sich es durchaus
lohnen kann, auch wirtschaftlich
umweltfreundlich zu sein.
Wisst ihr, wie ich mein? Also, wenn man
das schafft, umweltfreundlich die Sachen
zu produzieren, das ist jetzt schon
nen, nen Merkmal,
wenn das dann auch wirklich stimmt, was die Leute
dazu bringt, das zu kaufen. Also,
so komplett unsinnig ist das Ganze
gar nicht. Das finde ich an sich eigentlich ganz gut, dass man
das da dran sieht.
Naja, gucken wir mal weiter jetzt erstmal.
Äh, Giftsub.
Dankeschön. Leona Bomber hat
Sub gegiftern.
Carnetos, Carnetos
Good Subscription here.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr was? Ich muss jetzt auch, ich muss nochmal Pause machen.
Seit Apple damit
angefangen hat, mit diesen, mit diesen
Kameras, die so aus dem Gehäuse gucken,
machen ja viele Hersteller
nach. Ich glaube, einige
der aktuellen Samsung Top Smartphones, die
haben ja auch so Dinge, also Kameras, die rausgucken.
Es ist verständlich,
es ist verständlich, warum das so ist. Ich meine, du kannst
halt Linsen und Kameras besser, umso
kleiner, umso beschissener. Also, das verstehe ich schon, dass man
das so baut. Was ich ja persönlich
halt ein bisschen dumm finde, ist, dass
man das Handy nicht mehr flach auf den
Tisch legen kann, ohne Hülle
zu haben.
Ich habe hier auch ein iPhone 11, da guckt es
nicht ganz so krass raus, aber wenn ich
das iPhone 11 ohne Hülle auf den
Tisch lege, dann liegt es
nicht plan auf. Und das finde ich ehrlich
gesagt ziemlich kacke.
Gut, das geht schon ewig nicht mehr, das macht's aber
nicht besser, nur weil es ewig nicht geht.
Ah, yes.
Das habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen.
Das geht bei meinem 11er wahrscheinlich gar nicht, oder?
Limit Framerate.
Stimmt, die neuen haben jetzt
ja auch 120 Hertz oder sowas.
Stört das wirklich, wenn es sich
flach auf den Tisch legt? Ja, das stört.
Zum Beispiel, wenn es Vibrationsalarm
macht und dann so ganz komisch hin und her
wackelt auf dem Tisch.
Ich mag das überhaupt nicht.
Zumal ich das Handy auch ab und zu
auf den Tisch, gerade beim Essen mache ich
das so. Ich guck dann rein,
und dann ist es so, dass es sich nicht mehr auf den Tisch legt.
Ne, dass es Face ID
unlockt, entsperrst und lass es
flach auf dem Tisch liegen und tippt dann
darauf rum, sei es jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen Musik
hin und her machen so, ja, ich benutze
das total oft flach aufliegend.
Mir wird das mega auf den Sack gehen, wenn es nicht flach aufliegt.
...which is a high refresh rate display.
However, it can be capped via
software at 60 frames a second.
Will replacing the display have an
impact on this feature?
Other features to keep an eye on are the battery health,
True Tone and Face ID,
as these are problematic to repair on the iPhone.
Proceeding to open
our first iPhone 13,
I'll place it...
Das Apple Turn-In-Programm, das ist so halbe-halbe.
Das mag zwar, das mag vielleicht gut für die Umwelt
sein, zumindest sieht es auf den ersten Blick so aus,
ich glaube, das Apple Turn-In-Programm
ist aber aus anderem Grund entstanden.
Müssen wir mal gucken, ob es dazu Analysen gibt.
Meine persönliche Vermutung ist,
dass das Apple Turn-In-Programm halbwegs
attraktiv gehalten wird ist,
dass es auf dem Gebrauchtmarkt nicht so viele Apple-Geräte
gibt, weil Apple keinen Bock hat,
weil die Dinge auch lange
verportet werden, weil Apple keinen Bock hat,
dass ihre Geräte wirklich die komplette
Lebensdauer im Umlauf sind, sondern Apple
will ja neue Geräte verkaufen und
neue Geräte verkaufen ist dumm, wenn du für den
Hälfte der Preis ein
drei Generationen altes iPhone bekommst.
Das mag Apple nicht.
Also ich glaube, das ist aus
mehreren Gründen entstanden. Das mag zwar vielleicht auch
dem Umweltschutz zugutekommen, aber
ich gehe wie bei vielem davon aus,
wie bei nahezu allem, was
die machen und nicht nur Apple, dass das
vielleicht zum Teil was mit der
Umwelt zu tun hat, aber zum größten Teil
es um den eigenen Geldbeutel geht.
Wo man auch wieder sieht, wenn man es schafft,
Umwelt und eigener Geldbeutel zu
verbinden, dann ist das für die gesamte Menschheit
eigentlich die beste Variante.
Weil dann haben die alle einen Anreiz
was zu machen.
Ich weiß nicht,
irgendwie tut mir das immer, ich denke immer, es geht kaputt,
wenn ich da irgendwie einen mit so einem Saugnapf
und so einem Spachtel da, das auf
aufdingsen sehe.
Da muss man aber genau wissen, was man macht.
Garantie!
Cakewave, ja.
Bye bye, Garantie!
Warum ist da innen ein
Apple Logo? Das...
müssen wir Tim Apple fragen.
Achso, ja, wahrscheinlich um zu sagen,
dass das Originalteile sind.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, als würde es
in irgendeiner Art und Weise die
China-Chinesen davon abhalten,
eine Fake-Teile
zu machen, wo auch das Logo drauf ist.
Das juckt die doch mal
absolut überhaupt nicht.
Also,
die Chinesen kriegen da mittlerweile so gute Fakes
hin, da, also,
das ist denen auch egal.
Saures Master, danke für 700 Subs.
Wenn da das Logo drauf ist,
kann er Zeug kassieren, denn das juckt die Chinesen
doch nicht. Die Chinesen machen das,
dass es so aussieht, als wären es Originalteile.
Wobei man eine Sache mal den Chinesen
zugute halten muss, ja.
Die sind mittlerweile richtig, also die Chinesen
machen es genau richtig.
Die Chinesen, also, mal davon abgesehen, dass es verboten
ist, aber das ist in China ja wieder ein anderes
Problem. Die Chinesen machen es genau
richtig. Die Chinesen machen, fahren auf
der einen Seite die Schiene,
wir können die Sachen billig nachbauen,
die die Leute haben wollen,
und auf der anderen Seite haben die
mittlerweile auch, natürlich dann zu teureren
Preisen, haben die mittlerweile
auch ziemlich gute Produkte, die die Leute
kaufen wollen, obwohl sie wissen, es ist
ein China-Produkt.
Bestes Beispiel sind da die ganzen Xiaomi-Geschichten.
Das kaufen die Leute,
sie wissen, es ist ein China-Produkt, und sie
sagen, das ist für mich so attraktiv, dass ich das auch
zum bisschen teureren Preis kaufe, weil es konkurrenzfähig
ist, wenn nicht sogar besser und gerade
preis-leistungsmäßig besser, als von vielen
anderen Geräten, gerade die Staubsauger-Roboter
und sowas. Also, die Chinesen machen es
eigentlich genau richtig. Die haben billigen Fake-Kram,
den die Leute in Massen kaufen, und die
haben relativ gute, eigene, gebaute Sachen
mittlerweile, die die Leute auch kaufen.
Also, die haben quasi nichts, was es
nicht gibt.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern,
wie ich die, wie ich die iFixit,
das iFixit-Spachtel verbogen hab
im Stream?
Das wird uns ermöglichen, was funktioniert und was
von der Software blockiert wurde.
Dann können wir sehen, welche Teilen
die Fehler verursachen und welchen
Einfluss das hat auf die Reparabilität des
Geräte. Beginnen wir mit dem
blauen iPhone, ich werde die beiden Bracke
entfernen, die die Flexkabel für
die Batterie und das Display sichern.
Und das Dumme ist ja, wenn du bei einer Sache
nicht aufpasst, geht das Telefon nicht mehr.
Ist das WLAN?
Ne, Batterieanschluss.
Da sind überall QR-Codes drauf, warum sind
die QR-Codes drauf?
Wahrscheinlich, dass die Genius Bar
die Sachen besser tauschen kann.
Die nennen sich ja wirklich so.
Ich dachte am Anfang immer, das ist ein Witz.
Also, wenn du in so einen Apple-Shop gehst
und dort Support brauchst, beziehungsweise
dein Gerät reparieren lassen willst,
da musst du ja zur Genius Bar.
Und ich dachte früher immer, das ist ein Witz,
weil die so, ich dachte, also ursprünglich
dachte ich, das ist ein Witz, weil man
damit sagen wollte, hey, die Leute sind so
unfähig und das sind ja Genius, so in Anführungsstrichen.
Aber nein, das heißt wirklich Genius Bar.
One big change is the display's picture
and touch cables have been integrated
into just one.
Oh, ich würde mich das,
das würde ich mich nie trauen,
das würde ich mich nie trauen, ohne Scheiß.
Da musst du schon genau wissen, was Sache ist.
Das würde ich mich nie trauen, das hier mit einem
Plastikstück rauszuhebeln.
Im Leben nicht. Also ich würde mein iPhone
auch gar nicht ausmachen.
Aufmachen.
Removing the display from the gold iPhone 13 Pro,
it's now time to get out the logic board.
This can be done by removing the
SIM tray and the 13 cables connecting
to the board.
In removing just the display and now the
logic board, we've used four different
types of screws, two of which
are security screws.
Boah, das sieht wirklich aus, als kannst du da extrem leicht
was kaputt machen.
After the cables and two standoff screws have been removed,
the SIM eject pin needs to be moved out of the way.
Now the board is free.
Carefully maneuvering it out of the phone,
we can get a look at it.
Ich würde so viele critical information lecken,
um so ein Ding auszubauen.
Ich würde es definitiv kaputt machen.
Warum sind das Gold-
Connectoren?
Ich glaube die Gold- und Silber-Connectoren sind
einfach nur, dass man es nicht so verwechselt, oder?
Das muss kein wirklich
Gold-Connector sein.
In a similar design to previous iPhone
models, this iPhone board
has once again returned to having a
soldered-in SIM reader.
In the iPhone 12, the reader was modular.
I was able to upgrade a single-SIM
iPhone 12 to support two SIM cards.
But that won't be possible
with this model.
Now that we have one logic board out,
I'll need to retrieve the other one
before we can swap them across.
I want to make sure that the symptoms, if any,
are the same across the two devices.
As I'm working, I'm keeping
track of all of these parts and components
on several magnetic mats.
Laying everything out helps me keep track
of where things go when it's time
to reassemble.
It's now time to swap the two boards.
I'm not sure I'll ever be able
to reassemble the two boards
without breaking them.
And if I were to break them
without breaking them, I wouldn't be able
to reassemble them.
Does anyone of you dare
to reassemble
something like this?
I wouldn't dare to do that.
They're the same model of phone
and everything inside looks the same.
While the hardware of the phone
is identical, the software
of most components from the cameras
to the vibration motor have their own
serial number. If the software
we designed is...
...such a way that if those components'
serial numbers changed, it could break
or limit functions of the device.
This is what happened with the iPhone 12.
Exactly, that didn't work the last time.
You couldn't...
You could do the display and the...
...board, whatever's underneath,
but some functions didn't work.
Let's see how it is now.
Now that the board is installed,
everything else inside the phone
is from the other device.
Let's see how it reacts.
After pairing on, there are several
messages from the settings app.
Unlocking the phone displays an important
camera and display message.
Unable to be verified as genuine
Apple components. We also see
an unable to activate Face ID message.
Tapping learn more on any of these
messages will take you to Apple's website
where it recommends you to service your phone
at Apple. This is what we saw
with the iPhone 12, however the 13
takes it a step further, with
even more issues arising.
Das war klar, dass es nicht besser
geworden ist.
For those unaware, the battery health
has been purposely disabled, along with
Face ID and True Tone.
Digging a little deeper, I tested
a variety of functions on the phone.
Technisch ist das wahrscheinlich
komplett Nonsens.
Das ist absichtlich eingebaut worden.
Das ist Schwachsinn, dass das
irgendwie einen technischen Grund hat,
dass es so sein muss.
Portrait mode and the new cinematic mode
don't function correctly when using the
selfie camera. Cinematic mode allows you
to press record, but the time never
increases and no video is saved.
In portrait mode the background does not blur,
but you can see it detects my face,
and refuses to take an image,
saying to move further away.
No matter how far I move, it doesn't work.
This also tends to lock up the camera app
in the process.
Yep, kannst vergessen.
Before we jump into conclusions, I'll try to
replicate these issues on the other iPhone 13.
It will have the same setup as the other phone,
all genuine, new Apple parts,
just from a different phone.
After everything is connected,
we can test the phone.
At first, it wouldn't power on.
I don't know how this works.
I don't know how this works in Canada,
but in case of doubt,
it would take several years
to fix it.
Apple won't say,
that they built this to prevent
self-repair,
but Apple would say,
that it's a technical necessity.
So, first you have to prove to Apple,
that this is nonsense.
It will probably take 10 years to fix it.
But, what about the camera?
The phone has the same issues
as the other.
No battery health, no True Tone,
and no Face ID.
But what about the camera?
Well,
the temple OS guy
had the worst roof damage.
The temple OS guy
System zu entwickeln, aber das
Witzige ist, Gott hat ihm auch
genaue Vorgaben gemacht,
was das Betriebssystem haben soll.
Also Gott hat zum Beispiel gesagt, 16 Bit
Farbtiefe ist genug und sowas in der Richtung.
600, genau, Gott hat
gesagt, 640 mal 480
Auflösung.
Ich weiß nicht, was
der Typ hat.
Also der Typ hat echt
einen harten Knall.
Also der Typ hat echt einen harten Knall.
Ähm,
ja, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht steht das
im Wikipedia-Artikel
sogar, hallo?
Vielleicht steht das auch im Wikipedia.
Gibt's da einen deutschen Artikel? Nee.
Okay, jetzt zeig mal her.
Hier, hier, guck, guck.
Also, das ist
Terry Davis, das ist der
der sagt,
Spezifications, so, 640
mal 480 Resolution,
16 Color Display,
Single Audio Voice,
were instructed to him by God.
Der hat wirklich
einen hardcore Knall gehabt, der Typ.
Ja, das ist zu geil.
Aber eins zieht man
daran mal wieder, das muss
nicht zwangsläufig schlecht sein.
Also, anscheinend hat
es ja in ihm schon zu
gewissen Taten
animiert und in dem Fall
man könnte sagen, also quasi
sinnvolle Taten, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie wirklich sinnvoll
das ist, aber er hat zumindest was daraus gemacht.
Aber es ist schon der Wahnsinn.
Also, wie wirklich
pepega Leute im Kopf sein können.
Achso, das wurde auch übrigens in Holy C programmiert.
Normales C ist zu
unrein wahrscheinlich.
Ja, also der Kerl hat
wirklich einen hardcore Knall gehabt.
Also richtig, richtig mega heftigen Knall.
So, wo sind wir hier?
Apple.
So, weiter.
Weiter.
The same issues occur with both portrait
and cinematic mode.
It should be noted that the rear cameras...
Trotzdem ist es sätge.
Ja, ich glaube, da war ja sogar Obdachlos
dann später und so.
...work just fine.
Richtig sätge.
However, the issues don't end there.
Auto-Brightness ceases to function.
As you can see, there is no change
after switching the lights on or off.
Compared against another iPhone,
you can see how the phone should be responding.
As an attempted fix,
I'm going to restore the phone using iTunes
to iOS 15.0.
This may or may not fix these issues,
but there's only one way to fix it.
There's only one way to find out.
Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass man sein iPhone downgraden kann.
You can see, Face ID has not come back
into a working state.
As for the rest of the issues with the phone,
well, they're all still there.
In fact, the camera issues have changed slightly.
Now the camera has become more unstable.
Instead of viewing the image
and not being able to capture it,
the viewfinder now freezes
and only updates every few seconds.
This goes for both the cinematic and portrait mode.
Das ist komplett kaputt.
of the phone.
At a closer inspection,
the phone I erased
is on a different build of iOS 15.0.
It appears these phones shipped on a pre-release version.
I will update the other phone
to see if it gets the same results.
After updating,
we now have two phones
that have freezing camera viewfinders.
Somehow this update has caused more issues.
I have retested the phone
and everything else remains the same.
Wer hat sich diese Fake Glitches ausgedacht?
Was ist das für ein Problem?
Die gleichen Leute,
die sich Verspätungsgründe für die Bahn ausdenken.
Das sind wahrscheinlich die gleichen Leute,
Ich glaube, das haben die bestimmt crowdsourced
oder so irgendwo zu den gleichen Leuten.
We know what issues arise.
It's time to find out what actually...
Brauchst du ähnliche Gehirnareale für?
I'll be installing each of the logic boards
back into its original frame
and testing out a camera and display replacement
to see if that causes any of the issues we've just faced.
I'll be reattaching the original display for now,
so I can test if all of those issues disappear.
Pass auf, jetzt gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder alle Fehler sind gefixt
oder Apple merkt sich,
dass da mal ein falsches Display dran war
und ist nach wie vor kaputt.
Aber ich glaube, das geht jetzt einfach wieder.
Weil ansonsten könnten die das ja auch gar nicht...
Wollte ich gerade sagen.
Weil ansonsten könnten die es ja gar nicht tauschen.
Funktioniert.
Was macht die Auto-Briten nicht funktionieren?
Und was macht die Front-Facing-Kamera?
Und was passiert, wenn wir eine Display-Replacement machen?
Ist das sogar auch...
Absichtlich ist das eingebaut!
... ohne irgendeine Art von Funktionalität zu verlieren?
Na gut, lass uns das mal sehen.
Zuerst möchte ich die Klammer-Issue auf den Boden bringen.
Also werde ich die Front-Facing-Kamera
auf einem dieser Phones verändern.
Während wir hier oben sind,
werden wir auch...
Das ist so krass klein.
Das ist so krass kleinteilig.
Ich würde...
Ich hätte es zehnmal abgebrochen schon.
Ohne Scheiß.
Guck mal.
Die Kammer...
Die haben irgendeine Authentifizierung
oder irgendeine...
Checksumme.
Irgendwas.
Keine Ahnung.
Irgendein Handshake.
Passiert da zwischen Kamera und Rest.
Also das musst du ja aktiv einbauen.
Das heißt im Endeffekt...
Das heißt im Endeffekt,
ihr bezahlt quasi bei einem iPhone mit,
dass Apple diese Sachen eingebaut hat.
Weil das hat ja auch Entwicklungszeit
und Aufwand gekostet.
Also man bezahlt quasi mit seinem eigenen Geld mit,
dass man es nicht reparieren kann,
wenn man so will.
Aber gut, das muss man halt wissen.
Ich meine, es ist ja bekannt
und im Prinzip bezahlt man das willentlich mit,
wenn man Apple Geräte kauft.
Ich bin ja da auch schuldig.
Ich habe auch genug Apple Geräte.
Vielleicht checkt das iPhone nur,
wenn man die Kabel disconnectet.
Ja, dann dürfte es ja auch nicht...
Dann dürfte es ja auch nicht auf magische Art und Weise wieder gehen,
wenn man das Original anschaltet.
Das musst du schon erkennen.
Diebstahlschutz?
Na, ich weiß nicht.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht,
wie weit das was zum Diebstahlschutz beiträgt.
Das ist eh verschlüsselt da drauf, dein Zeug.
Und du kannst das ohne Passwort nicht entschlüsseln.
Also vollkommen egal,
ob da einer die Kamera austauscht oder nicht.
Um mit Fake-Hardware per Face-ID zu entsperren.
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel,
ob das möglich ist oder nicht.
Zumal es eine Original-Kamera ist
und es danach auch nicht funktioniert.
Nee.
Das klingt...
Also selbst wenn Apple das sagt,
klingt mir das doch hart vorgeschoben.
Würdest du ein 99...
Was würdest...
Moment, Moment.
Ich muss jetzt mal...
Ich muss das gerade mal kurz lesen.
Wirdest du ein 99 Euro Android-Phone
mit einem 99 Euro iPhone gleichsetzen?
Das kommt ja auf das Telefon an.
Das kommt auf das Telefon an.
Also ich habe ja selbst einige iPhones
und einige...
Ups.
Musik an, Mann.
Also ich habe ja selbst einige iPhones jetzt schon gehabt
und wir haben auch einige iPhones hier
und ich habe auch genug Android-Geräte,
dass ich schon so den...
Also was ich nicht habe,
muss ich gleich sagen,
ich habe kein Desktop-Mac.
Also ich beziehe das jetzt nur mal auf Android und iOS,
was Tablets und Smartphones angeht.
Also ich habe alles schon.
Ich habe alles auch schon mehrfach.
Ich glaube, ich habe mittlerweile...
Ich glaube, mit dem neuen iPad jetzt 12 Tablets
und so ungefähr...
So drei Viertel davon ist Android-Kram.
Auch ein bisschen höherpreisige ist zumindest eins dabei,
was mir überhaupt nicht gefallen hat.
Also ich muss sagen...
Also mal auf Tablets bezogen, muss ich sagen,
das iPad ist einfach meilenweit vor allen Android-Tablets,
die ich bisher hatte.
Sowohl von der Haptik her,
als auch von der Bedienung her,
als auch von der Geschwindigkeit her,
als auch generell von allem.
Also Tablet-mäßig würde ich sagen,
not even close.
So.
Smartphone-technisch kommt es eigentlich letztendlich darauf an,
was man haben will und was nicht.
Das kann man nicht sagen.
Das hat alles seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Also ich würde keinem, der Android verwendet,
einreden wollen, er soll jetzt ein iPhone verwenden
und ich würde keinem iPhone-Fan einreden,
der...
dass er Android verwenden soll.
Es sei denn, die Leute wollen irgendwas machen,
was halt weder mit dem einen
oder mit dem anderen nicht richtig geht.
Dann muss man natürlich sagen,
ja gut, Pech gehabt, ja.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel mein iPhone ordentlich automatisieren will,
dann klappt das nicht.
Du kannst iPhones oder iPads nicht ordentlich automatisieren.
Sowas wie Tasker gibt es nicht für iPhone
und ist auch technisch nicht möglich umzusetzen unter iPhone.
Das ist halt einfach Apple-Policy und deutlich restriktiver,
was Background-Apps angeht,
was automatische Eingaben angeht.
Also sowas wie Tasker und das ganze Plugin-Ökosystem
ist einfach unter iOS-Technik nicht möglich.
Das will Apple auch nicht.
So.
Was die meisten Leute aber gar nicht brauchen.
Für mich zum Beispiel als Dashboard an der Wand
für Heimautomatisierung ist ein iPad deswegen nicht brauchbar.
Deswegen habe ich da Android-Tablets hängen.
Aber beim Smartphone kommt es echt drauf an,
was man haben will.
Deswegen würde ich halt schon sagen,
wenn du ein Android-Benutzer bist
und ein Android-Phone haben willst,
dann ist ein 999 Euro Android-Phone bestimmt genau das Richtige.
Umgedreht würde ich sagen,
ja, ein 1.000 Euro iPhone ist wahrscheinlich genau das Richtige.
Also bei Smartphones ist wirklich die ganz entscheidende Frage,
was man haben will.
Ich würde mir kein 999 Euro Android-Phone kaufen,
weil ich die letzten Jahre zum größten Teil iPhones verwendet habe,
und ich damit rein aus User-Sicht,
ich will ja da nichts automatisieren oder sonst was
großartig auf meinem iPhone,
alles soweit machen kann,
bis auf ein paar Sachen, die mir auf den Sack gehen,
muss ich sagen.
Aber das insgesamte positive Bild überwiegt da für mich.
Deswegen würde ich mir auch weitere iPhones holen.
Wobei ich ja glücklicherweise gar kein iPhone holen muss,
weil ich das iPhone von der Firma, wo ich arbeite,
gestellt bekomme.
Aber das iPad und sowas,
das habe ich mir im vollen Besitz
meiner geistigen Kräfte gekauft.
Ich sag das einfach wie es ist.
Die meisten davon,
um es mal zu entwire flexen,
die meisten davon liegen rum und sind aus
oder sind auch keine wirklich teuren Tablets.
Also das meiste davon,
das ist zum Beispiel,
also die Tablets setzen sich zusammen
aus einem alten Tegra Note 7.
Das hängt zwar noch an der Wand,
wird aber nicht mehr verwendet.
Fire,
wie heißt die?
Fire HD 8
wird auch nicht mehr verwendet.
Zwei Fire HD 10s für das Dashboard an der Wand,
ein altes Lenovo Billig Tablet,
was ich damals von G2A bekommen habe.
Das war das einzige Lenovo Tablet,
was es gegeben hat, glaube ich.
Damals ein relativ teures,
glaube ich, um die 400 Euro Android Asus Tablet,
was ich nie wieder kaufen würde.
Das Tablet hat von Anfang an gesackt
und es hat nie, obwohl es neu war,
ich habe das Asus Tablet damals für meine Mutter gekauft
und
das Tablet war von der Verarbeitung her kacke.
Es hat viel zu kleinen Rand gehabt,
sodass du immer mit dem Daumen aufs Display gekommen bist
und Asus hat gesagt,
nachdem ich das Tablet gekauft habe,
Asus, genau,
dass ich das Tablet gekauft habe,
dass sie das jetzt einstellen
und nichts mehr daran machen.
Es hat nie was bekommen.
Übrigens, ich muss euch,
ich muss euch übelst lustiges Video zeigen.
Wartet mal,
wartet mal.
Ich habe es so,
ich habe mich so weggekackt,
weil einer gesagt hat,
Sus,
Tagesschau,
Jugend,
Jugendwort.
Das ist zu geil.
Ja,
ja.
das musst du euch angucken.
Aus ganz Deutschland können bis zum 18. Oktober
über das Jugendwort des Jahres abstimmen.
Diese Wörter stehen zur Auswahl.
Schisch,
Wild,
Digger,
Sass.
Grün.
Akkurat.
Sane.
Kapatastisch.
Geringverdiener.
Und Mittwoch.
Abstimmen können Interessierte über die Website des Landes.
Ich bin echt erstaunt,
wie quasi,
wie komplett,
wie soll ich sagen,
neutral und emotionslos man das sagen kann.
Zeitverlage.
Sass.
Ich weiß nicht,
ich weiß nicht.
ich weiß es nicht.
Und ich weiß nicht,
ich bin 37.
Ich habe es jetzt garantiert nicht mehr mit YouTube.
Aber irgendwie Digger finde ich am besten.
Digger,
Digger ist echt am besten.
Digger?
Digger.
Das ist zu geil.
Ich habe das Video bestimmt schon 20 Mal angeguckt.
Das ist auch immer so.
Das ist so doof.
So, wir gucken jetzt das iPhone Video endlich fertig.
So.
Ah, guck ab.
Oh, big brain time.
Big brain.
Also das Sensorkabel kommt ans Originale
und das Display kommt ans Andere.
Oh, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Jetzt ist es doppelt dran.
Pfeifertime, pfeifertime.
Siehst du, die machen wirklich irgendeinen Handshake
zwischen den Komponenten.
Du kannst es nur nicht mal richtig austricksen.
Wie geht da das, oder?
Ach nee, der wärmt das, um das zuzumachen.
Oh, Alter.
Also hätte ich es bis jetzt noch nicht kaputt gemacht,
jetzt wäre es hinüber.
After removing both cables,
we can interchange them between the two screens.
In this configuration,
we have a brand new iPhone screen.
Da darfst du auch kein Heißkleber drunter machen oder so.
Da kriegst du es ja immer zu.
Heißkleber wird da ziemlich hart.
...from another phone
with the sensor cable from this very phone.
In other words,
it should work perfectly fine.
Despite the genuine display message,
Face ID still doesn't work.
Tipp.
The only component in this entire phone,
that is not from the factory,
is the display panel.
The sensor cable remains the same.
The Face ID still doesn't work.
If you do it the other way around,
where you have the original display panel,
but a different sensor cable,
well, the same thing happens.
The Face ID this time will actually let you
into the menu to set it up,
but it will fail after just a few short seconds.
As with every issue I've faced in this video,
I've tried a factory reset using iTunes
just to make sure that the display panel
doesn't make any difference to the phone.
After resetting the device and retesting,
I found the exact same results.
That means if you damage your display
on this new iPhone 13 Pro,
you can say goodbye to the functionality of Face ID.
But that's not all.
With just replacing the display,
the selfie camera doesn't work correctly.
With portrait and cinematic mode
not being able to capture anything.
Auto brightness doesn't work,
and true telephoto,
has been disabled.
What is true tone?
Despite all of this,
the high refresh rate still works.
With that, it's finally time
to reassemble our iPhone 13s
out with all of their original factory parts
and hopefully they'll still be working by the end.
That's what we know.
Of course they'll still work.
We've seen that three times.
Of course it still works.
He builds it together,
switches it on,
bam, it works.
That's it.
I can attach the display being sure not to damage it.
As if I do,
a replacement will cause the phone
to have limited functionality.
Apple is able to pair new components to this phone
and avoid all of these issues discussed today.
However, this prevents third-party repair shops
or a DIY repairer
to really be able to repair the phone
and still have it work properly.
After giving the inside of the phone a good clean,
I can close it up
and proceed to reassemble the gold iPhone 13.
Ja, okay.
Ähm, das können wir jetzt skippen.
Wir wissen, dass es funktioniert.
Ja, das haben wir jetzt verstanden.
Das haben wir jetzt verstanden.
Das, äh, müssen wir uns nicht auf 5.000 mal anhören.
Ryzen 5000, best memory.
Das best memory ist eindeutig das mit den meisten RGB drauf.
Also in dem Fall würde ich sagen,
das rechte.
Das ist zufälligerweise auch das schnellste,
aber es kommt ja nicht auf die Geschwindigkeit an,
es kommt ja auf das RGB pro Zentimeter an.
Also das rechte ist das beste memory.
So.
Also was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
Ja.
Ich weiß, was wir uns angucken.
Wollte ich mir nämlich schon,
wollte ich mir nämlich schon heute Morgen
schon auf dem Handy angucken.
Was sagt die Gamestar zu New World?
Da will ich mal,
es geht nur 30 Minuten,
da bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Ähm,
kann von Gamestar testen, halten, was man will.
Ich finde es aber immer ganz interessant, was sie dazu sagen.
Und ich bin immer noch der Meinung,
leider ist mittlerweile fast alles Paid auf der Gamestar Seite.
Dass das in dieser Richtung die beste,
beste Game, Gaming Zeitschrift ist, die wir noch haben.
Ja, mal gucken, was sie dazu sagen.
Mal gucken, von wem das Video ist.
Es ist kaum zu glauben, aber New World ist endlich erschienen.
Und seit dem Release am vergangenen Dienstag macht das Spiel vor allem eins,
Schlagzeilen.
Vor allem darüber, wie schwer es aktuell ist,
überhaupt ins Spiel zu kommen.
Ich habe ja nun echt schon den ein oder anderen MMO-Launch erlebt,
aber so ein...
Ah, ich weiß nicht, wie er heißt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie er heißt, der Sprecher.
Ist das nicht der, der aussieht, als wäre er direkt aus Vikings?
...Hype wie bei New World gab es schon lang nicht mehr.
Von den über 600.000 Spielern am Launch-Tag
konnte gerade mal die Hälfte spielen.
Julius, ja, kann sein.
Die anderen standen teilweise auf Wagen.
Ja, kann sein.
Die Warteschlangen-Positionen im fünfstelligen Bereich.
Bei einer Kapazität...
Die haben keine Server-Probleme.
Die Server sind einfach voll.
Die sind bloß auf 2.000 Spiele ausgelegt.
Und ich glaube in dem Fall noch nicht mal,
dass es ein Design,
also dass es ein Skalierungsproblem der Hardware ist.
Ich glaube, das ist absichtlich.
Da steckt eine Design-Entscheidung dahinter,
die Server nur auf 2.000 Leute zu machen.
Keine wirklich technische.
Ja, aber ich sage euch,
die Leute werden sich in drei, vier Monaten zurückwünschen,
die Zeiten von heute,
weil dann alle Server, 60, 70 Prozent der Leute,
die abgehauen sind, die Server leer sind,
eventuell gemerged werden.
Mal gespannt.
Das Spiel hatte, glaube ich, 800.000 oder fast eine Million oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, übelst viele Spieler,
oder 500, ich glaube eine halbe Million.
Ich glaube eine halbe Million war es.
Eine halbe Million Spieler,
die es versucht haben einzuloggen zum Start,
das sieht man ja auch.
Guck mal, wir können einfach mal gucken hier.
Steam Stats New World.
Guck mal da.
757, ah gut, es ist jetzt, kommt das Wochenende.
Es ist quasi das erste Wochenende seit Release.
Fast eine Million.
Fast eine Million, Leute.
Und lasst uns mal im Februar gucken.
Wir gucken im Februar mal.
Und ich predikte mal, dass nicht mehr,
dass wenn es hochkommt, die Hälfte der Leute noch da sind.
Da bin ich, ich bin da wirklich gespannt drauf auf die Entwicklung.
Ich glaube nämlich,
die meisten Leute, die damit jetzt anfangen,
spätestens wenn die auf Max Level sind,
stellen sie fest, oh, ist nicht so meins.
Und dass die meisten der Leute, glaube ich,
mit dem Core-Gameplay,
also diesem Faction-Based PvP in New World gar nichts anfangen können.
Aber gucken wir mal.
So, was sagt die GameStar?
Neues Server nachzuliefern und haben bereits einen kostenlosen Transfer versprochen.
Ja, selbst ein Reminder.
Um nach dem ersten Release-Hype doch noch seinen Freunden nachjoinen zu können.
Ich bin Jules und habe mich die Woche jeden Morgen
nach dem Aufstehen eingeloggt,
um dann irgendwann nachmittags endlich spielen zu können
und euch jetzt in diesem Video meine ersten Eindrücke aus dem New World...
Hat das Spiel eigentlich mittlerweile eine Story?
In der Alpha hat es das nicht wirklich.
Es gab ein Intro und das war's.
Ich denke mal, jetzt in der Vollversion wird da schon ein bisschen mehr sein.
Wobei ich persönlich kein MMO spiele, um Storys zu spielen.
Wie kann man bei New World die Server merchen,
wenn auf jedem Server die Map...
Du musst dich für einen Stand entscheiden
und dann die Spieler, die Spieler-Daten
von einem zum anderen kopieren.
Was anderes sehe ich da, sehe ich da nicht.
... zu schildern.
Dieses Video wird euch präsentiert vom ultraschlanken ROG Gaming Notebook
Zephyrus M16.
Was? ROG Notebook?
Die super schmalen Bildschirmrenner und Dolby Atmos sorgt für...
... auch über diesen Launch...
Was man nämlich auch über diesen Launch sagen muss,
wenn man erst mal im Spiel ist, dann läuft es alles ziemlich rund.
Kaum Lags, die Gebiete sind nicht krass überfüllt, alle Quest-NPCs stehen da,
wo sie hingehören.
Wer schon mal ein paar MMO-Launches mitgemacht hat,
der weiß, dass das keineswegs selbst...
Wenn ich sowas schon sehe im Chat, die Übersetzung wieder...
Wahrscheinlich ist die Übersetzung sogar relativ gut.
Ich persönlich würde ja am liebsten spielen
mit einem englischsprachigen Client auf einem deutschsprachigen Server.
Das wäre so meine Lieblingsvariante, ja.
Der Ahnenwächter-Regent ist am Start.
... verständlich ist.
Beim Release von WoW Warlords of Draenor etwa war die Warteschlange vor dem
Einloggen noch das geringste Problem.
Ja, WoW-Laute.
Ich lachte nach acht Stunden Warten und dem nach wie vor sehr notdürftigen
Charakter-Editor mit nur ein paar vorgefertigten Gesichtern,
also endlich am Strand meines zufällig bestimmten Startgebiets.
Darauf habt ihr übrigens keinen Einfluss.
Ja, das war in der Alpha auch schon so.
Muss also Glück haben oder gleich am Anfang einen weiten Weg laufen.
Daran sieht man übrigens auch schon.
Ich meine jetzt übrigens nicht ihn hier im Video, sondern...
... die Leute, die sich darüber beschwert haben, dass das 99...
Okay, das ist vielleicht übertrieben, dass 90% der Leute absolute Kackbobs sind,
die oder Kacknoobs sind, die MMOs spielen.
Wir haben das Gleiche.
Ich habe auch mit zwei Leuten zusammen gespielt hier, als wir New World gestartet haben.
Natürlich war es auch so, dass einer nicht...
Es gibt, glaube ich, vier verschiedene Startgebiete und zwei hatten Glück.
Die waren im gleichen Startgebiet.
Du kannst auch so oft den Charakter neu erstellen, wie du willst.
Und dann hast du im Gleiche.
Aber es ist total easy.
Es ist wirklich total easy.
Die Weltkarte ist aufgedeckt, standardmäßig.
Und du musst nichts machen, außer die ersten 15 Minuten Quests.
Und dann kannst du zum anderen laufen.
Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Du musst die Quest machen, bis du in die Faction kommst.
Das dauert vielleicht eine halbe Stunde, 45 Minuten, wenn du da bist.
Und danach kannst du einfach zu deinem Mitspieler laufen.
Das dauert eine Viertelstunde.
Also es ist wirklich easy.
Aber die haben Leute, die checken es einfach wieder nicht.
Nach dem Tutorial sehe ich bereits andere Spieler um ein Lagerfeuer herumspringen und Dinge craften und weiß,
jetzt beginnt das Abenteuer.
Dieses allgegenwärtige Gefühl von Neuheit und Entdeckung rund um einen MMO-Release habe ich wirklich lange nicht mehr so erlebt.
Die Welt sprießt nur so vor Leben.
Die Hintergrundmusik aus New World?
In den Städten wird gehandelt und gecraftet um die Städte herum.
Die Hintergrundmusik kommt mir übelst bekannt vor.
Ist die aus New World?
... und bauen Lagerfeuer?
Ah! Das ist die Tutorial-Quest.
Und scheinbar hat die ganze Stadt sich genau einen Ort dafür aus...
Was ist die Hintergrundmusik?
Das ist doch nicht aus New World.
Die kommt mir übelst bekannt vor.
Haben sie das hier drin stehen?
Hm, würde mich echt mal interessieren.
... gesucht.
was ein bild
aber was macht new world denn jetzt so anders so neu
also zum einen wäre da das kampfsystem dass ich viel direkt
mehr ehrlich ist
das stimmt das stimmt leichte und schwere angriffe blocken und ausweich wirklich
muss akkurat gezielt werden und richtige timing ist dass das kampfsystem macht tatsächlich macht tatsächlich spaß
die musik ist aus dem über das gibt es ja ähnlich
es gibt auch stellen stellen ähnlich dem sonntag voller kann sein kammer übelst kam
akkurat kam übelst bekannt vor das kampfsystem macht tatsächlich macht tatsächlich echt spaß hat mir einfach auch spaß gemacht
aber new world macht gar nichts neu was new world macht ist new world macht sogar vieles älter als neu als neuere
mmo zum beispiel dass es ein spiel ist was viel auf spieler interaktion setzt was du
bei sag mal älter scrolls so gut wie gar nicht hast seine man steht da auf pvp
älter scrolls ist ja das solo quest mmo
kiosk 999 dankeschön für den sub
und
spieler interaktion ist tatsächlich was was was mir lange zeit in neuen mmo ist abgegangen ist also aus diesem gesichtspunkt
müsse die welt eigentlich genau das sein für mich
sobald die streamer wieder fort ein spiel ist hier alles wieder gut mit der warteschlange
Der hat nicht unrecht der typ das habe ich auch in einem der letzten videos gesagt viele der leute die jetzt auf new world springen machen
das weil sie mit ihrem lieblings-
streamer zusammen spielen wollen deswegen geht niemals in die streamer fraktion auf dem server es sei denn ihr wollt permanent gebiete verlieren
quick maps
dafür ist der chat new world auf allen lange hotbars werden wir wollen auf pc kommen
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob es auf was anderem als auf dem pc verfügbar ist
loki turner dankeschön für den sub ex aktives skills ausgerüstet haben drei pro waffe
das ist das muss man hier vielleicht noch mal kurz betonen was er hier sagt dass da habe ich auch so
dass meine bedenken dass es am anfang spaß macht aber am ende eigentlich richtig abkacken wird allen lange hotbars wir können immer nur sechs aktives
ausgerüstet haben drei pro waffe genau du hast im endeffekt nur drei skills pro waffe in new world
was auch wieder bedeutet du hast nach den ersten paar levels deine skills am start die du verwendest
danach speckst du noch ein bisschen
damage und passiv bleeding und gedöns aber du verwendest quasi ab levels von von
level von level 10 15 ab
bis
level
exakt gleichen skills
ich
das hat sich in der alpha nicht so schlimm angefühlt weil das kampfsystem sich irgendwie gut angefühlt hat aber ich habe da meine zweifel
dass das auf dauer irgendwie so der renner ist weiß ich glaube dass ich glaube das wird einfach zu schnell langweilig
wenn man es mal mit video vergleicht was das kampfsystem
angeht bdu ist natürlich vielmehr mit rumgeporte und
Immunity stellt und so was bei
irgendwelchen pvp kämpfen aber sagen wir so video hat auch ein relativ aktives kampfsystem
und dort hast du aber auch gleich mal irgendwie 20 skills pro pro klasse
und
also da habe ich echt meine zweifel viele mmo spieler kritisieren hier die fehlende taktische tiefe
mir macht das stärker auf reaktion getrimmte kämpfen aber gerade deshalb
da hat er recht das fand ich auch gut
optimiere ich meine rotation durch hast du final fantasy 14 gespielt ja 500 stunden oder so
als das erste anon raus war wir haben das erste anon komplett durchgespielt bis endgame damals alexander war damals endgame
und dann haben wir festgestellt nachdem wir das gemacht haben
also wir haben ja nicht irgendwie progress hard mode oder so gemacht
haben wir festgestellt es gibt nichts mehr das game ist fertig
es gab es gab nichts mehr in dem spiel zu machen
wir haben das wir haben das durchgesuchtet ein paar mal
wochen
und es gab nichts mehr es war einfach es war einfach durchgespielt
zumal es ja auch in final fantasy endgame technisch zumindest zum damaligen zeitpunkt nichts gab außer daily
währung sammeln oder weekly währung sammeln
und das meint es hat ein pvp ich glaube sogar pvp mit mit elo system mittlerweile aber ganz ehrlich das hat
mich da nicht großartig angesprochen zumal es capture the flag war
dafür ist es gedacht du spielst es durch bis zur nächsten expansion naja gut das problem ist
dass der fahrer und dem fabian wenn wir im spiel in der richtung wie krank das dann halt durch für zwei monate und dann sind wir
fertig und müssen dann zehn monate auf die nächste expansion haben ja vielleicht vielleicht sollten wir das noch mal spielen ich meine wir haben
wir haben den charakter auf endgame von heaven sword level
endgame heaven sword level das heißt das bringt dir gar nichts
das bringt dir gar nichts
das heißt wir müssen im prinzip jetzt zwei erweiterungen noch mal durch level und questens könnte man machen bis varen mal fragen ob
da bock drauf hat der richtigen reihenfolge in new world reagiere ich auf die bewegungen
der ist sorry ist final fantasy eigentlich immer noch angesagt es man gold hat es ja
eine weile gespielt aber da habe ich letztens wieder war spielen denn jeder treffer fühlt
sich richtig wuchtig an ja da der rechte ist das kampfsystem fand ich wirklich weiß ich
halte beim kämpfen in new world so viel spaß wie schon lange nicht mehr in einem mpg was ich auch
lange nicht mehr in einem mmo rpg erlebt habe ist ein derart generisches quest diese ja ja
fantasy 14 und die elder scrolls online in sachen storytelling ein anderes level erreicht gilt was
zwei punkte mit dynamischen eventen und rätsel gilt was zwei herzchen quest es also es hat mich
das gelangweilt man könnte jetzt sagen das ist ja das coole an gilt was zwei gewiss aber ich sage
euch gilt was open world herzchen quest die du alle ablaufen muss
das über die gesamte world map es hat mich so heftig gelangweilt zwar da waren sie hat mich
da richtig durch gequält durch gilt wo es zwei star wars die old republic liefert moralische
entscheidungen und selbst dauerbrenner wo w setzt inzwischen auf mehr abwechslung und ja hier spielt
er das noch ich habe letztens war spielen sie wieder hier stellt new world einen rückschritt
auf ganzer linie da ja das stimmt da recht meine aber das nicht schlimm jede ist gehe hier hin
das ab und an sollen wir noch unseren crafting aufgaben nach ich finde das überhaupt nicht
schlimm ist das ein tönig ist wenn ihr euren npc so einen satz sprechen lasst hat da nichts geklingelt
der mpc und dabei aber ich finde das übrigens überhaupt nicht schlimm wenn er so generic
quests haben ich finde das sogar cool das ist so im nachhinein das habe ich damals als ich noch ganz
viel da auch gekreidet habe also schon eine ganze weile her also früher als ich viel gespielt nie so
eine sache die ich da richtig cool dran fand ist dass das spiel keine main quest hatte in der form
von du bist der held der die welt rettet in dark warst du so ganz normaler 08 15 hans der darum
gelaufen ist und monster gebasht hat oder sachen gecraftet hat oder oder sowas du warst niemand
besonderes und das finde ich in dem mmo ehrlich gesagt auch genau den richtigen ansatz ich verstehe
es dass viele leute nicht gefällt viele leute wollen irgendwie das weiß ich der große auserwählte
sein irgendwie den dunklen herrscher besiegen irgendwie könig irgendwie von gebiet xy werden
oder sowas das ist für ein singleplayer story mag das alles ganz cool sein aber ich finde in
einem mmo passt das nicht es ist ja schon immer in einem mmo bisschen merkwürdig wenn du zum npc
gehst und der npc den sagt haus erwähnte du bist wieder hier hier bekommst du diese einzigartige
rüstungen da gehst du in die stadt und in der stadt läuft laufen 80 prozent auf einem level mit
der rüstung rum und sowas das ist ja ein bisschen ein bisschen komisch aber es ist auch ein bisschen
komisch, ja, deswegen finde ich
das ist mir nie so aufgefallen, als
ich das damals gespielt habe
und das fand ich im ursprünglichen World of Warcraft
ich habe ja nicht viel World of Warcraft gespielt, am ursprünglichen
World of Warcraft auch nicht schlecht, du warst
so ein 0815 Noob
der in der Welt unterwegs war
du warst niemand besonderes
und mittlerweile haben MMOs
auch so die Story, du bist der große
du bist der große Weltretter und
musst irgendwie den dunklen
Herrscher besiegen und sonst was, das passt
eigentlich zu MMOs gar nicht so richtig
weil, wie
kein MMO, Final Fantasy
ist übrigens das beste Beispiel dafür
kein MMO kann dir sinnvoll
erklären, warum jeder
Spieler, der einzelne Auserwählte
ist, der die Welt rettet, das wird
einfach ignoriert
in MMOs, das ist so, aber
und in Final Fantasy ist das beste
Beispiel, ja, du wirst ja
in der Final Fantasy 14 Story
zumindest, soweit ich die gespielt habe, wie gesagt
ich habe die nur bis Ende Heavensward gespielt
da geht ja die Story los
du bist so 0815 Dude, arbeitest
dich dann so ein bisschen mit Gildenquests hoch und
irgendwann stellen sie fest, du bist der
Warrior of Light und rettest die Welt
wie, Final Fantasy
er kann es bis heute nicht erklären
warum 5 Millionen Warriors
of Light Auserwählte rumrennen
und miteinander
Monster bashen, die eigentlich
jeder der Einzigen
Auserwählte ist, so nach dem Motto
das ergibt keinen Sinn, deswegen finde ich den Ansatz
deswegen finde ich den Ansatz
äh, wie die das hier machen
so super, super generic
äh, Quests ohne großartige Story
finde ich eigentlich für den MMO
genau den richtigen Ansatz
natürlich
gefällt das vielen Spielern, ich verstehe auch wieder
egal ob wir Nebenquests oder Hauptquests
machen, wären diese nicht anders
Übrigens, kann man eigentlich immer noch
nicht schwimmen in dem Spiel
in der Alpha hat man so eine ganz
komische
Unterwasserlauf-Animation gehabt
sah ein bisschen aus wie aus Fluch aus der Karibik
wo die mit dem Boot unter das Wasser
unter Wasser gelaufen sind
aber ich glaube man kann immer noch nicht schwimmen, oder?
also das ist schon ein bisschen
wie sagt man so ein bisschen
Cringe-Bruder heutzutage
dazu kommt, dass die Quests uns
teilweise gnadenlos auf halbe
Weltreisen schicken, nur um
an einem anderen Ort kurz mit jemandem zu
sprechen oder etwas aufzuheben
das ist gerade unter dem Aspekt der
nicht vorhandenen Mounds ziemlich
anstrengend. Ihr werdet in New World
sehr sehr viel Zeit damit verbringen
mit gedrückter Autorun-Taste auf euren
Bildschirm zu starren
gut, dass es Autorun hat
auch inhaltlich kann die Hauptstory mich bisher
noch überhaupt nicht überzeugen
wir sind nach unserem Schiffbruch auf dieser
Insel gelandet und sollen nun einen Weg finden
der Typ, das ist, also ich meine
mal ernsthaft, mehr
Generic Fantasy Cost kannst du gar
nicht bieten als, Moment, Moment
bisher noch überhaupt nicht überzeugen
als dieser Dude da
unauffälliger Typ mit kaputten
im Wirtshaus, also
unkreativer geht's da
nun wirklich nicht
ich find's auch immer so unauffällig, ne
auch, das fand ich übrigens auch bei
Assassin's Creed schon immer lustig
du läufst in das, ja gerade
gerade, guckt euch mal
guckt euch das 2er an, ja
da läufst du
durch, durch, nee, nicht Venedig
was war das, was war das in Assassin's
Creed 2
Florenz, Florenz war das, ne, Florenz
du läufst durch Florenz
ja, die Leute, ganz normal
am Start und du läufst da als
einziger Dude rum, mit so nem
Mantel, mit so ner krassen Kapuze
auf, tust so
übertrieben Stelzi an jeder Ecke
und niemand sieht dich
niemand sieht dich, niemand fällt dir auf
das ist alles vollkommen okay
du bist da der größte Stelze aller Zeiten
aber niemand bemerkt dich in Assassin's Creed
in Assassin's Creed
in Assassin's Creed 2
da hatten ja die NPCs irgendwie auch nur
2 Sprüche, wenn was war
ich kann mich noch an einen Spruch dran erinnern
wenn du einfach nur die Wand, wenn du einfach nur
mitten in der Stadt die Wand hochgerannt bist
da haben die, da haben die NPCs
gesagt, so sinngemäß sowas wie
äh, oh, was ist jetzt los
er muss verrückt sein
das haben die NPCs
alle 2 Sekunden gesagt
okay, next
Schiffbruch auf dieser Insel gelandet und sollen
nun einen Weg finden, die mysteriöse
Verderbnis zu bekämpfen, die das Land
bedroht, sehr standard
so, ja, tonal passt das aber auch leider
überhaupt nicht in die sonstige
sei frei, entdecke und baue
nach Lust und Laune Mentalität
wenn wir immer zwischendrin für einen
Handlungsstrang doch wieder der eine
Außerwählte sein sollen, der das mit der Bedrohung
aufnimmt
es passt, es passt auch überhaupt nicht
in das, hat er schon recht, passt auch überhaupt
nicht in das Game, das ist wieder so ein weiterer Punkt
dass man versucht hat
alles
in dieses Game irgendwie
reinzupacken
angefangen hat man mit einem PvP fokussierten
Game, was es ja im Kern immer noch ist
hat versucht da noch Quests reinzupacken, hat versucht
eine Mainquest reinzubauen, hat alles
irgendwie versucht reinzubauen
... habe ich die Story zum aktuellen
Zeitpunkt aber natürlich noch nicht zu
Ende gespielt
wage aber zu bezweifeln, dass mich da noch
etwas krass überraschen wird
wenn doch, Asche auf mein Haupt
leider bleiben sowohl die Spielwelt als
auch die NPC Charaktere in ihr zu
jeder Zeit völlig identitätslos
aber in New World
sind es eben die Spieler selber, die sich
innerhalb der Welt zu echten Identitäten
entwickeln sollen
und die Spieler typen die New World eigentlich an
so sollte es im Prinzip eigentlich auch sein
deswegen sage ich vom Ansatz her
so dass man mehr Spieler Interaktion
und Förderung, finde ich das eigentlich eine gute Sache
nur dass ich finde, dass New World einfach so
unzusammenhängend wirkt, ich kann das
echt schlecht beschreiben
sprechen möchte, denen werden die langweilige
Hauptstory und das banale Quest Design
nicht allzu viel ausmachen
die setzen ihre eigenen Ziele und
begeben sich in den befriedigenden
Grind der sich füllenden Balken
und oh mein Gott hat New World viele Balken
50 Milliarden Balken
nach dem Spielfortschritt ist den Entwicklern
wirklich gut gelungen
egal was wir in der Spielwelt tun
alles bringt Erfahrung und verbessert
unseren Charakter in irgendeinem Bereich
das ist auch sowas
ich habe zu jedem Zeitpunkt das Gefühl
an der
das ist, das ist mir in der Alpha auch aufgefallen
du hast ja wirklich 30 Milliarden Balken
ja du hast hier die, du hast XP
du hast Waffen, du hast Craft, du hast alles
du hast, du hast
also das sind jetzt die ersten, du hast wirklich überall
irgendwelche Balken, die Sache ist bloß die
wenn du mal 60 bist
und es da nicht irgendwas gibt
dann ist mit den Balken und der Motivation
daraus vorbei
vielleicht noch ein bisschen Crafting oder sowas
und genauso
ich, ich, ich
es kann sein, dass ich komplett falsch liege
aber wir gucken uns das mal an
wie gesagt, wir gucken uns das in 3, 4, wir gucken uns das
im Februar an, wir gucken uns das im Februar an
ich sage euch, die Hälfte der Leute
wenn nicht 70% der Leute, sind weg
... der Schwelle zum nächsten bedeutungsvollen Upgrade zu stehen
und so lässt sich der Grind
in Kombination mit dem bereits erwähnten spaßigen Kampfsystem
zumindest bisher mehr als gut ertragen
die entscheidende Frage ist, wie lange
denn im Gegensatz zu anderen MMORPGs
bietet New World aktuell noch recht wenig Endgame-spezifische Inhalte
ja, ach
MWOW fange ich jetzt erst an
ich fange erst richtig damit an, meine Ausrüstung zu optimieren
und mich Boss für Boss zu drehen
und das ist, und das ist an der Stelle
eigentlich der Unterschied
World of Warcraft ist
so wie die meisten, sagen wir mal so viele
MMOs, die da nachgekommen sind
quasi ein
Endgame
ich weiß gar nicht, ob es da ein Wort für gibt
äh, Item
Item
ja, äh
Item-Level-Upgrade-Spirale
was komplett useless wird
beim nächsten Add-on
also durchgestyltes Endgame
äh
Kreisel-Grind-Rate-Upgrade-Upgrade-Upgrade
nächstes Add-on useless
so, wieder von vorne
so, das ist das, wie World of Warcraft seit einer Weile funktioniert
und wie viele MMOs, die da nachgekommen sind
ähm
funktioniert hat
das ist ja da, wo sich das mit New World unterscheidet
und eigentlich ein Punkt, den ich im Prinzip ganz gut finde
New World
hat als Endgame
ja hauptsächlich, zumindest so wie sich das für mich jetzt darstellt
hauptsächlich
äh, PvP
so, und da ist halt die Frage, ob dieses PvP-System, so wie es jetzt ist
quasi
überhaupt Endgame-tauglich ist
also sprich, dass das was ist, was du am Tag auch mal wirklich 5, 6, also
es ist nicht jeder so ein Hardcore-Kreisel-Grinder wie ich früher
aber
die Leute müssen auch irgendwie zufriedengestellt werden, also ist das was?
was man 5, 6 Stunden am Tag machen kann
oder sogar
mehr
ja
alles in Kombination
kann man
will man das überhaupt machen?
das ist, das ist ja die eigentliche Frage
ja
vor allem, wenn man nur 3 Skills hat
also ich konnte da, damals, als ich, als ich in Dark noch meine, meine feste, feste
oder mehr oder weniger feste Gruppe hatte mit Leuten, wo ich gespielt hab
ähm
da konnten wir das ohne Probleme
6, 7 Stunden am Tag machen, wenn nicht länger
da sind, da bist du durchs Grenzgebiet gelaufen
hast alles weggebashed, was nicht bei 3 auf den, auf den Bäumen war
nebenbei noch ein paar Festungen erobert, verteidigt, gemacht
dann eventuell war noch irgendein Raid
den man, wo man für ein paar, paar Respec-Steine mitgemacht hat und sowas
du konntest da ohne Probleme
24, 7, 365 Tage im Jahr
durchspielen, wenn du wolltest
und du hattest dabei auch Vorteile dabei
du konntest nämlich
also in Dark war es so, ich, ich, ich
nehm das jetzt nur als Beispiel, weil
das ein MMO ist, was ich lange gespielt hab und weil es halt
bis heute das beste PvP-MMO ist
und New World geht ja auch in die PvP-Richtung
in Dark hast du bis 50 gelevelt
und dann, wenn du PvP gemacht hast
sei es jetzt, dass du Spieler gekillt hast
oder Burgen erobert hast oder Relikte gesammelt hast, was auch immer
äh, dann hast du zusätzliche Punkte bekommen dadurch
und dann konntest du quasi PvP-Fähigkeiten skillen
und du konntest dich mega OP spec'en, ja
du konntest beispielsweise als Heiler, konntest du dich mega OP specken, ja
du konntest beispielsweise als Heiler, konntest du dich quasi
dreimal komplett Mana wieder auffüllen und sowas in der Richtung
was du mit frisch Level 50 nicht konntest
was natürlich auch wahnsinnig motiviert hat, weiter PvP zu machen
weil du die Fähigkeiten sowohl PvM als auch PvP einsetzen konntest
und mal ganz ehrlich, so ein, so ein, so ein
Realm Rank 10 Character versus ein 50er mit 1
war halt not even close, du hast den halt, du hast den halt
mal kurz weggereckt
so, mit 3 Schlägen, 3 Crits, bam, weg
Evelynn Hexberg, das ist
ich weiß nicht, der Name klingt irgendwie sehr Casual-mäßig
man darf das anhand der Spielernamen vielleicht nicht festmachen
aber es gibt so, es gibt, es gibt Character Names, die schreien einfach so
irgendwie, hallo, ich bin ein Ultra-Casual-Spieler
was nicht schlimm ist, vollkommen okay
jedes MMO, der Großteil der Spieler sind einfach Leute, die das Spiel Casual nehmen, Beispiel
das ist, das ist gar kein Ding, ja
aber ich finde anhand der Namen erkennt man es teilweise schon irgendwie
also, wenn eine XXX der Pwner ist, dann ist das so, dass in New World
XXX der Pwner heißt
da weißt du gleich was Sache ist
der Werwe ist das Ziel entweder, der Weg das Ziel ist
es gibt eigentlich keinen wirklichen Grund bis zum Maximallevel zu hetzen
den die meisten persönlichen Ziele kann ich einfach auf dem Weg dahin schon genauso gut angehen
ich habe beispielsweise keinen Vorteil daraus, meine Craft ist in Stufe 60 zu leveln
im Gegenteil, ich bin eher gut beraten das die ganze Zeit nebenher schon zu tun
denn sonst wird mir im Endgame vielleicht etwas fehlen
dasselbe gilt übrigens auch für das Game
Punkt, warum ich jetzt gesagt habe, ich will kein
New World. Ich habe ja die Alpha gespielt.
Zwar nicht ultra viel, aber es geht
so. Das ist eines der Punkte,
warum ich jetzt,
ich meine, ich habe ja den Kram sogar auf
Steam, ja. Warum
ich letztendlich gesagt habe, New World
ist wahrscheinlich doch nicht mein Game.
Eines der großen
Säulen in diesem Game ist ja das Craften.
Und ich bin einfach jemand, ich mag
Craften nicht. Ich crafte
in keinem MMO.
Ich habe in keinem MMO groß gecraftet
und ich mag Craften
nicht in MMOs. Ich finde es gut, wenn es
Crafting-Systeme gibt, dass Leute
das gerne machen, das machen können.
Das ist voll komisch. Ich crafte
einfach nicht gerne. Crafting ist echt
nicht meins in MMOs.
Ich habe in keinem MMO groß gecraftet.
Auch das ist nicht in irgendeiner Form durch unser
Level beschränkt. Wir können uns nach der
Fraktionswahl nach etwa ein bis zwei Spielstunden
direkt für unsere Fraktion ins Getümmel
stürzen. Fans von
Open World PvP kommen hier voll
auf ihre Kosten. Überall
in der Spielwelt brechen größere Schlachten
zwischen den Fraktionen aus.
Das soll, was man hier sieht,
das müsste eigentlich der eigentliche Kern
von New World sein.
Das da.
New World macht deine Grafikkarte nicht
kaputt. Es sei denn, du hast eine minderwertig hergestellte
Grafikkarte. Das ist
Blödsinn. New World macht deine
Grafikkarte auch nicht mehr kaputt als andere Spieler.
Der einzige Grund,
warum New World so Probleme
macht bei Grafikkarten ist, weil die Leute
so lange in der Warteschlange sitzen,
und das Hauptmenü
nicht FPS-limitiert ist. Und deswegen
manche Grafikkarten überhitzen.
Aber wenn du eine ordentlich gebaute Grafikkarte hast, passiert
dir dabei gar nichts. Und du kannst es bestimmt auch anderweitig
limitieren. Wurde aber gefixt.
Da streiten sich die Leute,
streiten sich die Geister drüber, aber wie gesagt,
einem Grafikkartenhersteller liegt es auf jeden Fall nicht.
So.
Hierzu ist danach, das habe ich in der Alpha mir auch
angeguckt, da gab es ja in jeder Ecke Open World PvP,
weil die Leute sich einfach bashen wollten.
Das hier müsste eigentlich
der Haupt-
Und so war es, glaube ich, ursprünglich auch mal gedacht.
Bevor man quasi New World
von der ursprünglichen Idee umgebaut hat
zu dem, was es jetzt ist.
Das müsste der eigentliche Hauptgrund sein,
New World zu spielen.
Dauerhafte PvP-Action
Faction gegen Faction.
Das Problem ist jetzt nur, was man eingebaut hat
in New World.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es
wirklich ein Problem ist, aber ich finde halt,
daran sieht man, dass
das Spiel nicht so genau
sich festlegen will,
was es jetzt eigentlich machen will.
Du kannst dieses PvP hier, kannst du einfach
ausschalten.
Das ist halt fragwürdig, finde ich.
Also wenn du sagst, der Fokus
dieses Games soll eigentlich,
also die Motivation dieses
Games, er wächst quasi aus.
Open World PvP, Belagerung
und Gildenstellt,
dass du dann PvP einfach ausschalten kannst,
ist
fragwürdig. Also
ich weiß nicht, ob es eine gute...
Ja.
Egal, wir machen jetzt weiter.
...an denen ihr euch beteiligen könnt.
Das Open World PvP lässt sich nämlich
nach Belieben in den Städten ein- und ausschalten.
Ihr könnt, wie ich hier,
auch einfach zuschauen.
Bekommt eine Fraktion durch Open World PvP
und PvP-Quests genügend
Einfluss in einem Gebiet, kann sie
der regierenden Kompanie den Krieg
erklären. Der findet dann
meist am Folgetag zu einer bestimmten
Uhrzeit statt und die
kriegführende Kompanie kann aus allen
Spielern, die sich für die Schlacht angemeldet haben,
eine Truppe von 50 mutigen
Recken zusammenstellen, mit denen es
in eine große 50 gegen 50
Belagerungsschlacht geht.
Auch die gab es schon auf meinem Server,
leider wurde mein kleiner Charakter aber
bisher noch nicht ausgewählt.
Eine Wunde mit Leid.
Aber das ist es, was ich meine, wenn ich
sage, in New World machen die Spieler die
Identität aus. Dadurch, dass die
Städte von aus Spielern geformten
Kompanien geführt werden, die Bauprojekte
für die Entwicklung des Ortes in
Auftrag geben, sind die größten
Kompanien schnell auf dem ganzen Server bekannt
und ihre Anführer werden leicht
zu wichtigen Persönlichkeiten.
Das ist genau das Richtige
für so 0815
NoLife Leute.
So wie ich früher auch unter Fabian
MMOs gespielt habe.
Nur mit dem Unterschied,
wir haben beide,
ich meine, ich kenne den Fabian ja
ursprünglich sogar aus dem MMO,
wir haben beide gerne Leute gebasht,
aber gilden Anführer und
wie Städteplanung machen, hätten wir
beide keinen Bock drauf.
Wir wollen keine
Städteplanung machen oder sonst was, wir wollen
rausgehen und Leute bashen.
Am besten noch mit ein paar anderen Leuten, die auch gut
im Leute bashen sind.
Aber du hast garantiert genug
Leute, die dann übelst, ich kann
es mir schon so richtig vorstellen, es gibt
ein New World Roleplay
Discords oder sowas, wo
ich kann es mir wirklich schon bildlich
vorstellen. Ich meine, GTA RP,
ist auch so ein Ding, wo man sieht,
dass manche Leute sich da richtig krass reinsteigern
können. Aber ich kann es mir ja auch so
richtig vorstellen, dass dann der
aktuelle Stadtbesitzer in irgendeinen
New World
Roleplay Discord geht und dann
wird dann erstmal so der Fürst
geroleplayt oder sowas.
Es gibt so Leute, die stehen auf sowas.
Und gerade, dass es gut ankommt,
sieht man ja auch bei GTA
RP. Ich hab da ja mal,
also GTA RP,
also ich nehme mich nicht aktiv dran teil,
aber ich guck ab und zu mal
ein paar Clips
da draus, kommst ja kaum vorbei
und du hörst das manchen Leuten an,
die steigern sich da so
krass drin rein.
Also die roleplayen
nicht mehr, die sind das schon.
Die roleplayen dann wirklich
Polizist und
denken irgendwie hier,
das ist teilweise
richtig heftig.
Dementsprechend müsst ihr aber auch sehr gut organisiert
und zielgerichtet vorgehen, um
einen solchen Posten selber einmal
innezuhalten. Aktuell schaue ich mir
das ganze jedenfalls nur ein wenig von
außen an, während sich die großen
Gilden um die verschiedenen Städte prügeln.
In der Leitung einer solchen von Spielern
bewohnten Stadt steckt sicher viel
Spaßpotenzial, an das wir aber nur
mit jeder Menge harter Arbeit und
ein wenig Glück herankommen.
Nicht nur der PvP Aspekt lässt
sich wahlweise ignorieren, allgemein
lässt sich New World auch sehr gut als Solo
Spieler erkunden. Und dadurch, dass es
keine festen Klassen gibt, könnt ihr sehr
einsteigerfreundlich erst einmal wild
alle Waffentypen durcheinander probieren
und kombinieren, bis ihr etwas
gefunden habt, das sich für euch gut anfühlt.
Einzig in den Expeditionen
nimmt New World alte MMORPG
Traditionen auf und erfordert
ganz klar die Holy Trinity.
Unsere waghalsige
Draufgängertruppe wurde hier jedenfalls
gnadenlos aufgerieben, sodass
wir uns dann doch um eine richtige Kombination
aus Dengheiler...
Wer sich fragt, das grüne drumherum ist
so ein Aria-Heal.
Das kann man nur, wenn man diesen
Heal-Staff gespeckt hat.
Boah, das habe ich ja noch nie gesehen.
Was ist denn hier los?
Looking for Heal ist normal.
Looking for DD?
Moment, jedes Game hat nur DDs.
Tank und Healer gibt es nicht.
Looking for DD? Was ist denn da los?
Da, sus, wie man so schön sagt.
Da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Da stimmt nichts.
Looking for DD?
Nee, es luckt nie jemand.
Es luckt eigentlich jeder nur für Healer und Tanks.
...mussten.
Mir ist natürlich durchaus bewusst, dass ich
noch lange nicht alles gesehen habe.
Ein abschließendes Urteil zum aktuellen
Zeitpunkt zu fällen wäre völlig
unmöglich. Aber nach vier Tagen
mit New World kann ich zumindest einen
Ersteindruck geben und dabei gleich
entwarnen. Nein, New World
ist kein gescheitertes Spiel wie die
vorherigen Versuche der Amazon Game Studios.
New World ist ein sehr solides Spiel
und ein willkommener
frischer Punkt, in dem so sehr von den
alten...
Mal gucken, so ein MMO entscheidet sich ja nicht unbedingt
jetzt zwei Wochen nach Release.
...RPG-Genre.
Der wahnsinnige Spiele-Andrang in den ersten Tagen
zeigt, dass es diesen frischen Wind dringend gebraucht hat.
Das stimmt, da hat er recht, aber der Streamer-Andrang kommt auch...
Der Spieler-Andrang kommt auch durch den Streamer-Andrang.
...die bisher spielen konnten, zeigen sich auch größtenteils von dem Spiel begeistert.
Aber New World ist nicht für jeden etwas.
Es deckt kein so breit gefächertes Spiel... Und es... Ja.
Genau. Das werden, denke ich, viele noch merken, die jetzt gerade da eingestiegen sind.
...dort kann ich Hardcore-Raiden, PvP-Spielen, beim Questen eine stringentere Hauptstory erleben,
Mounds und Haustiere sammeln und und und.
New World richtet sich mit seinem Mix aus Survival, Crafting und klassischen MMO-Mechaniken
hingegen vor allem an einen Spielertypen.
Wer Spaß daran hat, sich in einer Ordnung... Wer hat denn... Alter, was ist das denn?
...Sack.
Die rustikale Küste im Dörfchen Erstes Licht.
Finde diesen trendigen und unwiderstehlichen Urlaubsort.
What?
...einen Spielertypen.
Wer Spaß daran hat, sich in einer offenen Sandbox-Welt seine eigenen Ziele zu setzen
und diese zu verfolgen und einen so wenig wie möglich vordefinierten Charakter zu optimieren,
auch wenn das Optimieren oft um des Optimierens Willen passiert und nicht in Hinblick auf
ein großes Endziel wie etwa einen Raid-Boss, für den könnte New World genau das sein,
was er gesucht hat.
Wer in einem MMO-Welt ist, findet diesen trendigen und unwiderstehlichen Urlaubsort.
Wer im MMO aber eine spannende Story mit erinnerungswürdigen Charakteren erwartet und Motivation eher
aus abwechslungsreichen Aufgaben statt aus sich füllenden Fortschrittsbalken gewinnt,
dem könnte in New World meiner aktuellen Einschätzung nach ganz schön schnell langweilig werden.
Ja.
Da gehe ich auch von aus.
Ich habe mich in diesem Video jetzt vor allem darauf konzentriert, die einzelnen Aspekte
des Spiels zu bewerten.
Wenn ihr einen Überblick darüber haben wollt, wie zum Beispiel das Skill- und Attributsystem
genau funktionieren, dann schaut doch gerne mein Vorschau-Video an, das ich vor einigen
Wochen gemacht habe, da erkläre ich das nochmal im Detail.
Und wenn ihr zufällig auf dem Server Ravenel in der Fraktion der Marodeure seid, dann lasst
euch doch von meiner Kompanie, der Brot-Legion, rekrutieren.
Vielleicht schaffen wir das ja zusammen, doch mal die Regentschaft einer Stadt an uns zu
reißen.
So.
Ich bin jetzt fast am Ende der Warteschlange.
Ich muss also gleich weitermachen.
Ich muss jetzt weiter spielen.
Die Marodeure-Brot-Legion.
Danke euch fürs Zuschauen.
Euer Jules.
This corruption must be stopped.
So.
Ähm.
Ich wollte jetzt hier noch irgendwo was zu sagen.
Zack.
Alter, ist ja gut.
Chat.
Seid aber aktiv heute.
So.
Ähm.
Moment.
Hier.
Da wollte ich was sagen.
Als halbwegs ausgeschnitten, wie ein Evolution nichts Grundlegendes Neues.
Ihr wollt eher wie eine Evolution nichts Grundlegendes Neues.
Ich würde sogar sagen, es ist eine Defolution.
Gibt es sowas?
Was ist das Gegenteil von Evolution?
Defolution?
Rückschritt.
Keine Ahnung.
Also vieles, was New World heutzutage macht, ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt
in MMOs.
Also.
Nicht.
Ne.
Das stimmt nicht.
Nicht angesagt.
Deforged.
Genau.
Ähm.
Sondern die machen vieles, wie MMOs quasi früher das gemacht haben.
So.
Äh.
Relativ persistenter Server mit einer relativ versicherten Stabilität.
Also.
So.
Ist halt so.
Ge sympathetic 3.
Also, And view 3 das habt ihr halt Bali igual Madrid, Wave vielleicht doch in den
anderenンダ
Red schon wo ihr seid.
Ja.
Ich kenne das nicht, aber allein schon der Titel und dass es vom NDR ist, das ist, das tut schon weh beim Titellesen.
Gaming, okay, was sagen Gaming, soziale Medien, Internet nach einer Studie, bla bla bla,
nutzen 700.000 Kinder und Jugendliche in Deutschland Computerspiele riskant und pathologisch, was bedeutet pathologisch in dem Zusammenhang?
Ich, in dem Zusammenhang, die Pathologie betreffen, ach nee, krankhaft.
Krankhaft, ah, krankhaft.
Daddeln bis der Arzt kommt, Alter.
Welcher Bube hat diesen Satz wieder geschrieben?
Daddeln bis der Arzt kommt.
Okay, wir gucken uns mal den Anfang an.
Das ist bestimmt ein ganz, ganz schlimmes Painschamp-Video.
Ups, Moment, wo sind wir?
Die Dislikes, ah, das heißt ja auf YouTube mittlerweile.
Ist das so ein PS3-Controller?
Nee, das ist ein PS4-Controller, das hat diesen komischen, dieses komische Touchpad.
Das hat das Touchpad, das ist ein PS4-Controller.
PS5-Controller, hat das eigentlich auch noch dieses komische Touchpad oder ist das jetzt weg?
Ah, das sieht jetzt aber anders aus, okay.
Bam.
Haha, genau, so sitzt man immer vorm Rechner.
Bam, bam, so spiele ich auch immer mit dem Controller.
Bam!
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
Der echte Gangster war einfach seiner Zeit voraus.
Ich hab den 82 mal getötet und er mich 18 mal.
Durchschnittlich verbringen...
Das ist Black Ops 1!
Moment, nee, das ist, das ist Black Ops-Dings, Firing Range Remake, oder?
...fünf bis sechs...
Nee, nee, nee, doch nicht, doch nicht, doch nicht.
Das ist vier, das ist Firing Range Remake, ja, ja, ist, okay, Moment mal, das Intro muss ich mir jetzt nochmal angucken.
Und bam!
Ich hab den 82 mal getötet und er mich 18 mal.
Durchschnittlich verbringen...
Moment, 82 in einem TDM? 82 in einem TDM?
Sus.
Da hab ich meine Zweifel.
Private Match.
...fünf bis sechs Stunden täglich am Bildschirm.
In der Pandemie ist es deutlich mehr geworden.
Das sind Internetfreunde.
Wir haben uns in der Corona-Zeit kennengelernt.
Internetfreunde.
Sie werden immer jünger.
By the way, soll ich euch was sagen?
Internetfreunde?
Wenn man sich mit Leuten gut versteht, das können durchaus...
Man kann das einfach Freunde nennen.
Wo ist das Problem?
Also, wenn man sich mit Leuten im Internet gut versteht...
Äh...
Ich wüsste nicht, warum man das großartig unterscheiden müsste.
Egal, egal.
Ist painstampig.
Digitale Medien schon im Kindergarten.
Ja.
Wir schaden den Kindern.
Oh nein!
Der Spitzer!
Der hat mir jetzt gefehlt.
Fuck, Alter, was kommt denn als nächstes?
Ein Helfer oder was?
Das ist nicht meine Meinung.
Das ist medizinisches...
Oh, Spitzer!
Wie sollen sich Eltern verhalten?
Spitzer, nicht Schwitzer!
Wir können schlecht in der Erwachsenenwelt immer sagen,
Digitalisierung ist das Heilmittel für alle möglichen Probleme,
die Gesellschaft hat und dann gleichzeitig so eine romantisierende Vorstellung von Kindheit haben,
die möglichst nur im grünen Wald stattfinden soll.
Für manche wird das Zocken zur Sucht.
Sie landen in der Kinder- und Jugendpsychiatrie.
Und vernachlässigt sein kann.
Der Typ, der ist eigentlich, wenn man sich solche Reportagen anguckt,
der macht auch Vorträge und so zu diesem Thema,
der ist relativ bekannt und der ist halt komplett gegen Medienbenutzung bei Kindern.
Der hat schon durchaus sinnvolle Punkte,
wobei der mir deutlich zu aggressive ist mit seinen Ansichten.
Ich glaube, er ist ganz extrem.
Man isst nicht mehr so viel wie vorher, trinkt jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Wachbein.
Also in der Zeit, wo ich viel gespielt habe,
habe ich eigentlich mehr gefressen, vor allem mehr vorm Computer als vorher.
Bleiben nur Energies, verliert die Interessen,
man macht nichts mehr mit Freunden,
man will eigentlich nur noch wirklich an seine Konsole und zocken.
Computerspiele und soziale Medien.
Ja, heute spielt man halt mit seinen Freunden zusammen.
Das mit Suchtfaktoren spielt.
Die Spieleindustrie hat somit eine hohe Verantwortung
und entzieht sich leider bisher jeglichen...
Spieleindustrie will Geld verdienen.
Zocken ohne Ende.
Wann ist es Computerspielsucht?
Ich bin ja auch kein Fan von vielen Glücksspielmechanismen in Spielen.
Aber jetzt weniger aus diesem Hilfe für unsere Kinder,
sondern eher, weil es die Spiele schlechter macht
und mehr Fokus darauf gesetzt wird, zu gucken,
wie kann man den Leuten möglichst easy ohne Gegenleistung Geld aus der Tasche ziehen
und am besten sie drei, vier, fünfmal für das gleiche Spiel bezahlen lassen.
Also mein Problem mit diesen Sachen ist eigentlich,
dass es die Spiele unterm Strich schlechter macht.
Natürlich ist es für einige, da haben die nicht unrecht,
ist es natürlich auch problematisch.
Digitale Medien in Kinderhand.
Ein Reizthema zwischen Eltern und Kindern.
Ich kenne keine Familie, wo es nicht so ist.
Überall ein ständiges Verhandeln,
Regeln werden aufgestellt, gebrochen, Streit Tag für Tag.
Ich bin noch mit nur drei Programmen aufgewachsen.
Bei uns wurde Fernsehen stark limitiert.
Gezockt habe ich nie.
Aber meine Kinder fahren total darauf ab.
Na, dann ist sie ja eindeutig die Beste, um diese Reportage zu machen.
Ich bin unsicher.
Am liebsten würde ich ihnen dieses Daddeln ganz verbieten.
Denn auch wenn die vereinbarte Zeit vorbei ist,
gibt es sowieso immer noch Diskussionen.
Andererseits gehört das heute wohl dazu.
Zocken tun alle.
Aber filmen lassen will ich nicht.
Aber filmen lassen will sich kaum einer dabei.
Ja, Moment!
Ich würde mich auch nicht filmen lassen,
wenn ich gerade auf dem Klo kacken bin
oder einfach nur durch den Garten laufe oder so.
Ich will überhaupt nicht gefilmt werden.
Diese drei Jungs, alle 15, stehen dazu.
Wollen aber auch, dass ihre Namen nicht genannt werden.
Also wir machen ja selber Kampfsport.
Und das ist auch so ein Kämpfspiel.
Deswegen, es macht halt Spaß.
OI!
Was haben sich denn da für Three-Hat-Leute rausgesucht?
Alter!
Na gut, 15.
Da kann man nichts erwarten.
Nach der Schule oder so, wenn man kommt,
ist halt langweilig, wenn man im Fernsehen guckt
oder am Handy spielt.
Können wir auch individuell reden und spielen noch?
Wissen Sie?
Ja, genau.
Wir spielen so Spiele, die man zusammenspielen kann.
Wir spielen zu dritt ein Zwei-Spieler-Game.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das sind zwei...
Wie wollen die das zu dritt eigentlich spielen gerade?
Da macht das viel mehr Spaß.
Mein Gott, so ein Kick, ne?
Ach ne, die spielen gar nicht zu dritt.
Der eine guckt zu.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ja.
Also meine Eltern sagen...
Die zeigen uns das doch jetzt nur...
Was ist denn das auch für ein Monitor?
What the fuck?
Sehen wir hier 1995 oder was?
Einmal ganz davon abgesehen,
die zeigen doch jetzt absichtlich so ein Klopp-Dings hier Spiel,
weil sie sagen können, hoho, gefährliche Prügelspiele oder sowas.
In Wirklichkeit, realistisch betrachtet, würden die eigentlich da sitzen und Fortnite spielen.
Oder was auch gerade Warzone oder sowas auch gerade angesagt ist.
Wenn ich Playstation spiele, werde ich schon aggressiv und bin anders drauf, als ich sonst bin.
Und stimmt das?
Ja, also ich merke das auch selber.
So ist das bei meinen Kindern auch.
Ich glaube besonders aggressiv ist er, wenn ihn in Warzone irgendein Cheater wegohnt.
Erschreckend.
Zumal man als Eltern irgendwann wohl ganz die Einflussmöglichkeiten verliert.
Ich treffe einen Professor, der Gaming nicht verteufelt
und sogar noch Vorteile für Kinder darin sieht.
Sie würden ihre sozialen und kognitiven Fähigkeiten trainieren.
Videospielen bedeutet Problem lösen.
Und zwar kontinuierliches Problem lösen.
Sehr komplexe Informationen müssen in hoher Geschwindigkeit verarbeitet werden.
Es müssen permanent Entscheidungen getroffen werden.
Gehe ich links, gehe ich rechts, hüpfen, ducken.
Das ist jetzt sehr vereinfacht ausgedrückt, aber da hat nicht unrecht.
Man soll die Denkleistung, die dort erbracht wird, nicht geringschätzen.
Das stimmt.
Man sieht es ja allein schon daran.
Ohne Scheiß.
Legt euch fünf Stunden hin und macht nichts.
Oder spielt fünf Stunden richtig, richtig intensiv was.
Nach den fünf Stunden intensiv irgendwelche PvP-Geschichten
oder irgendwelche Competitive-Sachen gespielt, hast du Hunger?
Wenn du fünf Stunden gelegen hast und nichts gemacht?
Nicht.
Wo habe ich eigentlich mein Eu3Head-Emote?
Wo ist denn das hin?
Ich finde es nicht, Leute.
Ihr müsst mir mal kurz helfen.
Ich finde mein Emote nicht.
Wir gucken sofort weiter.
Wo habe ich mein Eu3Head-Emote?
Wo ist es?
Seht ihr es irgendwo?
Da!
Ich habe es!
Okay, wo ist es?
Hier?
Ich sehe es nicht.
Es ist neben Stonks.
Ah, hier.
Das hängt halb aus dem Bildschirm raus.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Okay, wir können weiterkommen.
Spiele trainieren komplexes Problemlösen und sie sorgen dafür, dass junge Leute ihre
grauen Zellen anstrengen.
Ja.
Und zwar häufig in einem höheren Maße, als es die guten alten Schulaufgaben tun.
Warum?
Weil Videospiele Spaß machen.
Die jungen Leute wollen ihre grauen Zellen anstrengen.
Und habt ihr schon mal gedacht, dass zu viel spielen, dass das so ein bisschen Zeitverschwendung
ist?
Oh ja.
Weil ganz früher, ne?
Da habe ich, sollte ich lernen, aber habe gespielt.
Ganz früher, ne?
Das ist halt, ist nicht so gut.
Könnte man lieber die Zeit in andere Sachen investieren, die besser sind.
Die drei machen jetzt viel Spaß.
Die drei machen jetzt viel Sport.
Ja.
Aber wenn sie von früher sprechen.
Das sagt er doch jetzt auch nur, weil sie ihn so danach gefragt haben, die vom Fernsehen
da sind, oder?
Damals, vor allem der Typ ist 15.
Was ist denn damals?
Vor einem halben Jahr oder wie?
Das ist übrigens ganz wichtig.
Es ist, es ist unglaublich wichtig, dass der, dass sie im Zimmer alle eine Kappe aufhaben
und dann noch eine Sonnenbrille.
Ist das nur ein paar Monate her.
Ja.
Also früher bin ich ehrlich, ich habe früher echt oft gespielt.
Also richtig, richtig oft.
Also halt Nacht durch und alles.
Und daran habe ich auch gemerkt, das macht den Kopf nur kaputt.
Also ich schlafe auch viel schlechter und alles.
Okay, das stimmt.
Der Schlafrhythmus ist richtig dann kaputt.
Das stimmt schon.
Macht das gar keinen Spaß.
Also wenn man, ja, also wenn man den ganzen Tag wirklich nur gesessen hat, vorm Rechner
oder vor der Konsole, sonst wie eben gespielt, man hat das Problem, dass man erstens permanent
weiter, weiter über das Game denkt.
Nachdenkt.
Mädchenzocken auch.
Und dadurch, dass man sich nicht bewegt hat.
Dass man, dass einem auch irgendwie so der körperliche Ausgleich fehlt.
Deswegen im Prinzip das machen, was ich in meinem letzten Video auf YouTube erzählt
habe.
Da ging es zwar ums Thema Stress.
Da bist du, genau, da bist du, bist du, bist du Vogue.
Vogue bist du dann.
Was ich erzählt habe, du musst dich einfach ein bisschen bewegen und dann ist das alles
überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Es ist alles Kacke.
Es ist fast, es ist fast alles Kacke, wenn du, wenn du nichts anderes den ganzen Tag
machst als das.
Das kannst du eigentlich auch fast alles übertragen, wenn du den ganzen Tag nur eine Sache komplett
machst und dann wieder pennen gehst, dann ist es in der Regel, egal was es ist, eigentlich
nicht gut.
So.
Aber andere Spiele.
Ist das so?
Und sie kommunizieren viel über soziale Medien.
So wie Laura, die parallel mit ihren Freundinnen chattet.
Das, okay.
Das machen, das machen Typen natürlich nicht.
Die, also, nein.
Also, das heißt Kati und das heißt Lena.
Und du bist.
Ich bin in deinem Mitsprachen.
Das ist Roblox.
Eine Spielveranstaltung.
Und du bist.
Ich bin in deinem Mitsprachen.
Das ist Roblox.
Eine Spielveranstaltung.
Ist das, ist das Roblox?
Am Computer.
Das Freizeitverhalten hat sich von meiner zu ihrer Generation ganz schön verändert.
In Wirklichkeit ist es so, die Mädels sitzen hier mit, mit, mit, mit ihren, mit ihren Freunden
im, im, im, was weiß ich, was ist, das ist nicht Discord, Zoom wahrscheinlich oder so
und spielen Roblox.
Die Typen sitzen noch echt im Zimmer und ballern ein bisschen.
Und realistisch betrachtet wäre es eigentlich so, die Typen würden auch daheim sitzen,
hätten Discord an.
FaceTime.
Okay.
Hätten Discord an.
Und wären, keine Ahnung, im Montana Black Discord, würden die den ganzen Tag chillen
normalerweise.
Oder ich weiß, sie hat dann überhaupt einen Discord.
Ich verfolge das nicht so.
Also das wäre eigentlich die realistischere Variante.
Ich habe mit meinen Freundinnen noch echte Puppenhäuser eingerichtet.
Oh.
Da kann man hier halt auch die Farbe auswählen.
Alter Roblox.
Das ist.
Was finden die Leute eigentlich an Roblox?
Ich glaube, da bin ich zu Boomer für.
Alles, was ich von Roblox sehe, sieht einfach.
Extrem.
Abgefuckt.
Billig.
Aus.
So.
Billig.
Sieht Roblox aus.
Roblox sieht aus, wie als hätte sich jemand einen Unity Editor aufgemacht und einen Overlay
Asset Pack gekauft und hätte dann drei Dinge rein Track und Dropped.
Roblox sieht alles so unglaublich billig aus, was ich davon sehe.
Das kann man dann halt so lange machen, bis man mit der Küche sozusagen.
Zehn bis siebzehnjährige verbringen fünf oder sechs Stunden am Tag vorm Rechner.
Im Durchschnitt.
Während des Lockdowns kamen noch 75 Prozent dazu.
Ohne Homeschooling wohlbemerkt.
Reine Daddelzeit.
Ja und?
Einer, der die Kontrolle.
Was sollen sie denn?
Was?
Vor allem gerade während Corona?
Was sollen sie denn sonst noch großartig machen?
Spielen komplett verloren hat.
Gegen die Wand gucken.
Ist der 18-jährige Lukas.
Seit acht Wochen erholt er sich auf der Jugendsuchtstation im UKE.
Wir machen sein Gesetz.
Wir machen sein Gesicht unkenntlich.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ihr macht nicht sein Gesicht unkenntlich.
Ihr filmt ihn von hinten.
Unkenntlich.
Okay, ich weiß.
Sie schwenken jetzt gleich rüber.
Ich habe sehr, sehr viele Ego-Shooter gespielt.
Zum Beispiel Apex Call of Duty.
Halt Ballerspiele würde ich jetzt sagen.
Ja, das ist so.
Ich wette mit euch.
Die haben das fünfmal aufgenommen und haben jetzt das so so diese dieses Ding genommen, weil er das richtige Wort gesagt hat.
Aber auch.
Kreative Spiele, Minecraft.
Fortnite.
Oder Rennspiele.
Need for Speed, Forza, Horizon.
Und das ja teilweise zehn, zwölf Stunden.
Aber wenn es dann wirklich schlimm war, auch mal 72 Stunden.
Was ist das dann?
Warum kann man nicht aufhören, wenn man da drinnen steht?
Es ist jetzt.
Ja, wenn ich.
Ich stelle mir gerade vor, 72 Stunden Minecraft spielen.
Oh, dann hätte ich aber auch Probleme danach.
Dann wäre ich auch richtig, richtig der.
Beispiel nehmen würde bei Destiny 2 zum Beispiel.
Da brauche ich.
Ja, da gibt es verschiedene Waffen, die man sich erfahren kann.
Manche Waffen.
Da braucht man dann acht Stunden für.
Dann gibt es Rates, die man laufen kann.
Okay, da kann ich nichts.
Da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Ich habe nur nur mal ein paar Wochen lang mit dem Fabian Ultra Casual Destiny gespielt.
Also Ultra Casual heißt, wir haben acht Stunden am Tag das Game durchgerusht, bis wir da keinen Bock mehr hatten.
So viel zum Thema.
Wir haben das Addon irgendwie in einem Tag durchgespielt.
Halbtage oder was auch immer.
Zumindest ich kenne mich.
Ich kenne mich mit Destiny nicht so großartig aus, muss ich sagen.
Aber war das nicht so, dass in Destiny sogar der.
Der mögliche Progress stark beschränkt war auf die Woche.
Du musstest.
Du musstest den Tag abwarten, wann der Händler da ist.
Du konntest dir nur irgendwie so viele Dinger kaufen die Woche.
Du konntest das nur so und so oft machen.
War das nicht.
War das eigentlich nicht in Destiny eher so, dass ich so der Ultra Hardcore Grind gar nicht richtig gelohnt hat in Destiny?
Zumindest ist das so mein Eindruck gewesen.
Sechs, sieben Stunden.
Man will der Beste sein.
Gut, sechs, sieben Stunden ist ja an sich ist ja an sich kein Problem.
Spielen von Videospielen wird Sucht erzeugt dadurch, dass man nicht immer belohnt wird, wenn man was richtig macht.
In dem Falle, wenn man also jemanden tot schießt oder irgendwas anderes, wofür man wofür es Punkte gibt.
Sondern man erhält nur dann Punkte, wenn der Zufall auch noch mit entscheidet.
Und diese gleichzeitig sozusagen durch die eigene Aktion ermöglichte, aber dann erst per Zufall gesteuerte Zuweisung von Belohnung.
Das ist das, was am süchtigsten macht.
Das wissen wir.
Spielen für ein Glücksgefühl, das immer schwerer zu erreichen ist.
Da ist schon was dran.
Wer aufhört, verliert alles bereits Erreichte.
Dazu ein enormer sozialer Druck.
Lukas wollte sein Online Team nicht im Stich lassen.
Einmal alle zwei Wochen bin ich zum Arzt gefahren.
Um mir eine Krankmeldung zu holen.
Ja, aber sonst, es bestand halt nur aus Zocken.
Ich saß nur in meinem Zimmer.
Meistens dunkel.
Man verlernt den Kontakt zu anderen Menschen.
Ich habe irgendwann Probleme gekriegt, dann wirklich was mit anderen zu machen, weil ich Angst davor hatte.
Online ist es nämlich viel einfacher.
Oh, oh, oh, ich habe auch Probleme mit anderen Menschen was zu machen.
Das liegt aber daran, weil ich anderen Menschen in der Regel absolut nicht ab kann.
... in Kontakt zu treten, weil man sie halt nicht...
Man sieht die Mimik und die Gestik der anderen Leute nicht.
Man hört eigentlich nur die Reaktion übers Headset an.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Aber...
Weiß ich...
Also...
Vor allem, warum muss da eigentlich ausgeblurrt werden?
Ist das jetzt so ein Kniff vom Fernsehsender, dass das irgendwie spektakulärer aussieht?
Oder wollte er das wirklich nicht?
Ich meine, ich will gar nicht bestreiten, dass es solche Fälle gibt, wo das wirklich ernsthaft
äh
auf das Leben so große Auswirkungen hat, dass sie nicht, dass sie nicht mehr...
Die Doku ist von vor zwei, zwei Wochen oder so.
... dass sie nicht mehr ihr normales Leben leben können.
Ich kenne da sogar auch Leute, die damals...
Ich muss jetzt leider das Beispiel bringen, weil ich habe da jetzt in letzter Zeit...
What the fuck?
... wenig Erfahrung drin, die in World of Warcraft teilweise ihren Job verloren haben.
Das war ja, das war ja wirklich so eines der Dinge...
Ich glaube, das kennt jeder irgendeinen.
Also, wenn ihr in dieser Zeit aufgewachsen...
... wachs...
... wachsend seid,
ähm, kennt jeder irgendeinen, mindestens irgendeinen, der mit World of Warcraft, was weiß ich,
von Frau, Freundin bis Job irgendwas verloren hat, weil er es richtig verkackt hat.
Das, das war ja fast schon, das war ja fast schon Standard.
Ähm, klar kann das wirklich Probleme verursachen.
Aber, was ich bei diesen Dokus immer ein bisschen doof finde, ist,
dass da mit, dass da so mit dieser Einstellung drangegangen wird,
ne, das muss ich anders sagen,
dass da halt mit den Voraussetzungen des letzten Jahrtausends drangegangen wird.
Das ist dann von Leuten für Leute, die mit Leuten reden, die quasi da überhaupt keinen Bezug zu haben,
und die über Leute reden, die, ähm, ja, für sie quasi fast schon in einer anderen Welt, äh, sind.
Also, das kann man...
Die gehen immer in die gleiche Richtung.
Na, wir gucken jetzt mal weiter.
Dass der Typ jetzt vielleicht wirklich ernsthafte Probleme hat, will ich gar nicht bestreiten.
Und, ja...
Kann schon sein.
... wenn man dann wirklich mit Gestik und Mimik dann konfrontiert wird, ist das schwer.
Man hat dann irgendwann Angst davor.
Wisst ihr, was ich verlernt hab?
Jetzt ohne Scheiß, weil ich wirklich ver...
Jetzt muss ich mal sagen, eine Sache, die sich bei mir,
die ich nicht durch die Spiele, sondern die ich durch, äh, weil ich jetzt quasi seit,
ja, was weiß ich, äh,
bin jetzt 37, sagen wir mal seit 20 Jahren, 20, 23 Jahren oder so,
äh, sehr viel vorm PC,
wisst ihr, was ich wirklich verlernt habe?
Ich hab verlernt, mit der Hand Schreibschrift flüssig zu schreiben.
Kann ich nicht mehr.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
Ich kann schon auch schreiben mit der Hand, das ist kein Problem.
Ich kann Sachen ausfüllen und so, das ist kein Ding.
Aber so Schreibschrift, wie man sie in der, in der Schule gelernt hat,
das kann ich nicht.
Ich kann nur Druckschrift schreiben, ja.
Ich, ich, also ohne Scheiß, ich, ich, ich, ich fülle mit, ich, ich fülle mittlerweile,
ich fülle mittlerweile alles in Druckschrift aus.
Du durftest nicht mehr Schreibschrift schreiben.
Also ich kann das nicht mehr.
Also, ne, also, wenn ich, wenn ich, wenn ich irgendwie was ausfülle, ausfülle,
dann schreib ich, dann schreib ich wirklich dann hin,
Max, so.
Na, jetzt vielleicht nicht so.
Aber früher, ich überleg grad, wie sah das überhaupt aus, Schreibschrift?
Irgendwie so?
Ja, ich hab, ich, ich kann das nicht mehr.
Ich kann das nicht mehr.
Ich hab das verlernt.
Ich bin voll, ich bin, also wenn einer wirklich von mir will,
dass ich mal was längeres von Hand schreibe, dann bin ich richtig lost.
Konfrontiert wird, ist das schwer.
Man hat dann irgendwann Angst davor.
Sein Kind im Netz zu verlieren, der Horror aller Eltern.
Meiner auch.
Sein Kind im Netz zu verlieren.
Alter, was ne Aussage.
Ist es dann weg?
Guckst du, das ist, das hört sich jetzt so an wie, du, du, dein Kind geht nach dem Mittagessen ins Kinderzimmer
und
dann gehst du zwei Stunden später hoch und guckst ins Kinderzimmer.
Hoch!
Wo ist es hin?
Mottcheck!
Es ist weg.
Es, es ist einfach nicht mehr da.
Das Ventil.
Im Hintergrund stünden immer auch andere Schwierigkeiten.
Nicht jeder übermäßige Gebrauch hat tatsächlich auch Krankheitswert.
Es kann sehr gut angehen, dass in pubertären Problemlagen
die Jugendlichen exzessive Spielverhalten aufzeigen über Wochen oder auch über Monate,
dass sich aber auch ohne jede Intervention wieder zurückbilden würde, weil die nicht schwer beeinträchtigten Jugendlichen merken,
dass übermäßiges Spielverhalten sie in anderen Lebensbereichen einschränkt.
Also ich spiele bei weitem nicht mehr so viel wie früher mittlerweile.
Mag aber auch zum größten Teil mit daran liegen,
dass es weniger Games gibt, wo ich mich so richtig reinsteigern kann.
Also bei den meisten Leuten regelt sich das alles von allein.
Gehe ich jetzt von aus.
Als süchtig gilt, wer die Kontrolle über die Spieldauer verloren hat.
Über zwölf Monate hinweg müssen soziale Kontakte, Hobbys und die Schule da niederliegen.
Erst dann ist es Sucht? Ich finde das krass.
Da niederliegen?
Und Lukas ist nur einer.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was ist daran krass?
Er sagt ja quasi, sie findet es krass.
Also es muss erst richtig harte Auswirkungen haben, dass es als Sucht gilt.
Ja was denn sonst?
Wenn ich was mache und parallel alles andere zufriedenstellend erledige,
verwende ich ja wohl genug Zeit auf die wichtigen Sachen.
Warum ist es krass, wenn es dann erst als Sucht gilt?
... verloren hat.
Über zwölf Monate hinweg müssen soziale Kontakte, Hobbys und die Schule da niederliegen.
Erst dann ist es Sucht?
Naja, was denn sonst?
Was denn sonst?
Wenn du alles auf die Reihe kriegst, trotz fünf Stunden Spielen am Tag,
dann ist es ja wohl alles kein Problem, oder?
Ich meine, okay, du magst vielleicht süchtig sein nach irgendeinem Spiel,
aber du hast es zumindest insoweit im Griff, dass nicht dein restliches Leben darunter leidet.
Also du denkst vielleicht, wenn du auf der Arbeit...
Man kennt ja jeder, was weiß ich, es kommt ein neues Game raus, was ihr super nice findet,
und ihr sitzt dann auf der Arbeit und denkt euch,
ah, ich würde mich am liebsten jetzt einloggen und weiterspielen.
Aber ihr macht das nicht.
Es ist erst so richtig hardcore Sucht, wenn ihr sagt, okay, ich gehe heute nicht auf die Arbeit, weil ich spielen will.
Das ist ja was anderes.
Und wenn man das nicht macht, dann ist es auch keine Sucht oder zumindest nicht krankhaft.
Das ist ja das eigentliche Problem.
Und da sehe ich überhaupt kein Problem drin.
Ich finde das krass.
Wahnsinnig krass.
Krass, richtig krass.
Die Leute machen was, was ihnen Spaß macht, was sie irgendwie erfüllt
und was keine negativen Auswirkungen auf ihr Leben hat.
Krass, Alter, richtig krass.
Muss verboten werden.
Die Leute sind doch nicht dumm.
Außerdem funktioniert das, wenn das nicht bei allen, wenn das nicht bei allen Altersklassen in irgendeiner Art und Weise funktionieren würde,
könntest du dir Werbung komplett schenken.
Aber die Leute sind doch nicht dumm.
Ja, die könnten auch RTL Tag und Nacht oder wieder, nee, Berlin Tag und Nacht heißt das, ne?
Oder so, gucken.
Das würde es auch nicht besser machen.
Und dennoch.
Medien sind fester Bestandteil ihrer Wirklichkeit.
Nicht erst seit der Pandemie wird die Digitalisierung im Unterricht vorangetrieben.
Ist ja auch wichtig.
Wir reichen uns die Hände.
Sogar erste Kitas in Deutschland setzen bereits auf digitale Bildung.
Zum Beispiel dieser Kindergarten.
Ich könnte das nie machen.
Ich glaube, ich, also generell arbeiten mit Menschen wäre für mich der Horror.
Arbeiten mit Kindern als Kindergärtner, das wäre ja, also, weiß nicht,
dann würde ich mich vielleicht,
dann würde ich mich, glaube ich, echt aus dem Fenster stürzen oder so,
wenn ich das machen müsste.
Das wäre vorbei.
Das würde ich, das würde ich, das würde ich nicht ertragen.
... in Hamburg.
Tablets, Mikros, Kameras und Smartboards sollen die Kreativität der Kleinen fördern.
Werden begleitend, nicht ersetzend im Kita...
Ich finde es geil, dass es Leute gibt, die sowas machen können.
Ja, wirklich Hut ab, dass man das aushält.
Ich, ich könnte mir das bloß einfach nicht vorstellen.
Stripes07 sagt, könnte das.
Hey, jeder will.
Ich finde es super.
Ich finde es wirklich nice, dass es Leute gibt.
Ich könnte das nicht.
Das wäre für mich nicht möglich.
Die Medienkompetenz, die wollen wir fördern und wollen wir den Kindern beibringen...
Ja, ist auch gut so.
... dass Medien nicht immer nur Spaß ist, sondern wir haben auch einen kritischen Blick.
Wenn, wenn der Internetausbau in Deutschland schon nicht funktioniert...
Darauf, ja, im Endeffekt sollen die Kinder halt auch schon auf die Zukunft vorbereitet werden,
weil spätestens in der Grundschule geht es dann los.
Und wenn die Kinder dann schon durch die Kita Vorerfahrung haben,
ist natürlich der Einstieg in der Schule einfacher.
Ja.
Ist das, ist das ein Tablet?
Habe ich das richtig?
Ist das ein Tablet, was irgendwie so einen Gummieinband hat,
dass es nicht kaputt geht, wenn man es sich auf den Kopf haut oder so?
Wahrscheinlich eher, wenn man es runterschmeißt.
So lange, bis der Bildschirm anspringt.
Einen ganz normalen und kompetenten Umgang sollen die Kinder hier verinnerlichen.
Mit Erfolg, sagt die Kita.
Tablets hätten ganz schnell ihre Suche.
Das ist ein Amazon Fire.
Und nun nur noch den gleichen Reiz wie Bauklötze.
Ich glaube, dass es sinnvoll ist, auch im Kindergarten digitale Medien zu thematisieren,
auch den Umgang damit.
Guck mal, die sind richtig, die sind richtig hip.
Die schreiben den ersten Buchstaben kleiner als den zweiten.
... zu ermöglichen, weil sie eben Bestandteil jener Lebenswelt sein werden,
die unseren Kindern in der Zukunft bevorstehen wird.
Genau.
Aber müssen Kita-Kinder wirklich schon Spielzeug programmieren
und wissen, wie sie digitale Vorhersage machen?
Ja, warum nicht?
Warum nicht?
Für mich gehört ein Tablet-Diplom nicht zwingend zu einer glücklichen Kindheit.
Warum, warum denn nicht?
Wo ist denn das Problem?
Das ist doch gut, wenn die Kinder nicht komplett weltfremd in der aktuellen Zeit aufwachsen.
Die Kinder müssen kein C++ lernen.
Ja, okay, das...
Es gibt eine Menge Studien, die zeigen...
Also, Kinder C++ beibringen im Kindergarten würde ich tatsächlich nicht machen.
Dann ist kein Wunder, wenn die ihr Leben nicht auf die Reihe kriegen.
Danach ist vorbei.
Aber dass man im Kindergarten schon Umgang lernt mit Fotobearbeitung und Tablets und sowas,
das finde ich vollkommen gerechtfertigt.
Das ist doch sinnvoll.
Du kannst doch...
Die Zeiten ändern sich halt.
Die Kinder heute wachsen nicht mehr so oft wie ich.
Ich habe bis, keine Ahnung, bis 13, 14 hatte ich keinen Rechner.
Warte mal, lass ich mal rechnen.
Ja.
So.
Ich glaube...
Nee, 98 hatte ich schon.
Half-Life, Half-Life 1 hatte ich schon.
Vor 96 hatte ich also, sprich...
Sag mal 12, 13.
Bis 12, 13 hatte ich keinen Rechner.
Ich habe das gemacht, was man damals von den Kindern sich...
Wie man das sich auch denkt.
Ich bin viel draußen rumgerennt, ja.
Habe mich beim Fahrradfahren verletzt oder was auch immer.
Aber die Zeiten sind halt anders.
Heute ist halt nicht mal 1984 oder 1990, sondern heute ist 2021.
Für mich gehört ein Tablet-Diplom nicht zwingend zu einer glücklichen Kindheit.
Es gibt eine Menge Studien, die gezeigt haben, dass digitale Medien das tun, was sie immer tun, nämlich ablenken.
Und wenn man beim Lernen abgelenkt ist, lernt man weniger.
Und dann wird immer argumentiert, naja, aber ich muss doch wissen, wie die funktionieren.
Nun, die sind heute so einfach, dass jedes Baby sie verwenden kann.
Ah ja.
Man muss das also nicht wissen.
Ist das so?
Dann wird argumentiert, wir brauchen Medienkompetenz, damit man Fake News von Nicht-Fake News unterscheiden kann.
Völliger Blödsinn.
Weil sie können Wahrheit von Falschheit nicht durch irgendeine allgemeine Fähigkeit unterscheiden.
Die gibt's gar nicht.
Sie können nur Vorwissen haben.
Und je mehr sie wissen auf einem Gebiet, ich zum Beispiel in der Medizin, da kann ich sehr schnell sagen, das ist Blödsinn und das taugt was.
Weil ich Ahnung von Medizin habe, nicht weil ich Medienkompetenz habe.
Das würde mich jetzt mal interessieren, wie ihr da drauf kommt.
Also das erste Gegenbeispiel, was mir dazu einfällt, ist,
dass man sehr wohl zum Beispiel lernen kann, wie man Suchmaschinen bedient.
Und man merkt den Unterschied zwischen Leuten, die das geübt haben,
beziehungsweise wissen, wie sie schnell Sachen über eine Suchmaschine finden und anhand der Suchergebnisse schon direkt einschätzen können,
welche Seiten was taugen und welche nicht.
Also das merkst du, ob das jemand geübt hat, ob da jemand Erfahrung drin hat.
Und du kannst auch ziemlich gut im Internet relativ...
Also...
Sag ich jetzt.
Ich meine, vielleicht dauert das eine Weile.
Ziemlich gut dazwischen unterscheiden, was Scam ist und was nicht Scam ist.
Was meint ihr denn, warum so viele Leute auf irgendwelchen sinnlosen Scam im Internet reinfallen?
Weil sie Kack-Noob sind, weil sie keine Ahnung haben, was da Sache ist.
Die bekommen eine Mail von Sparkasse.de und denken sich,
oho, die Sparkasse möchte mein Passwort kontrollieren.
Nein, die Sparkasse will nicht dein Passwort kontrollieren.
Das ist irgendein China-Chinesen-Scammer, der dein Passwort kontrollieren will.
Also, ich frag mich, wie er da drauf kommt.
Der hat sicherlich in...
Sag mal so...
Im großen Gesamten nicht Unrecht, wenn er sagt, dass Medien ablenken.
Aber das kannst du nicht so pauschal damit irgendwie wegbügeln.
Naja.
Spiele wie Call of Duty kosten 70 Euro und mehr.
Der amerikanische Entwickler verdient aber auch viel Geld durch Zusatzinhalte,
die die Spieler sich runterladen können.
Damals haben wir viel Geld in Spiele investiert.
Ja, sehr viel Geld.
Okay, investiert ist vielleicht der falsche Begriff dafür.
Investieren bedeutet ja, er hat das Geld da reingesteckt,
nur er bekommt da irgendwie mal was raus.
Das ist glaube ich bei Call of Duty der falsche Begriff.
Natürlich wisst ihr, was er meint.
Und ja, das ist ein Problem, das finde ich auch nicht gerade sinnvoll.
Das versucht wird den Leuten quasi immer mehrfach, zweifelhaft,
zwei- bis dreimal für das Spiel Geld aus der Tasche zu ziehen.
Was ich da halt dumm dran finde, ist, dass die Spiele dadurch meistens nicht besser werden.
Bestes Beispiel ist das letzte Star Wars Game, wo Helden drin waren,
wo du hättest, glaube ich, vier Monate für grinden müssen,
aber du hättest es ja auch kaufen können.
Bis jetzt immer noch.
Weil mit diesem Geld konnte ich mir richtig gute Klamotten holen.
Also da war schon unnützes Geld für Playstation rauszugeben.
Wir haben bestimmt locker 1000 Euro oder so.
Locker, wenn schon.
Locker.
Wenn schon mehr.
Okay, der Witz ist ja, dass die Klamotten und Sachen für das Game genau aus dem gleichen Grund ausgehen.
Das ist ihnen glaube ich gar nicht so klar.
Sie geben in-Game Geld für Call of Duty aus, weil sie dann krassen Dark Matter Skin oder was auch immer am Start haben.
Und sie geben, weil sie dann in-Game auf dicke Hose machen können.
Und sie geben Geld im Real Life aus,
weil sie sich irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, was ist gerade so angesagte Klamottenmarke, keine Ahnung, anziehen können.
Gucci Cap.
Weil sie da auf dicke Hose machen können.
Der Grund, warum die Geld reinstecken, ist genau das gleiche.
Quasi Status in einer gewissen Gruppe.
Und ich bin mir mal gar nicht sicher, ob man jetzt sagen kann,
dass es prinzipiell besser ist für eine Gucci Cap 50 Euro.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was sowas kostet denn sowas.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Vor allem sieht das vom Muster aus, als hätte das mein Opa mal aufgehabt, Alter.
Hey, dann gebe ich, dann gebe ich lieber 30 Euro für einen Season Pass aus.
Dann gebe ich lieber 30 Euro für einen Season Pass aus.
Dann sind es wahrscheinlich nur China-Chinesen-Fakes, ja.
Aber ich würde mal gar nicht so sehr sagen, wer bestimmt denn bitteschön?
Wer bestimmt das?
Wer legt fest, dass es sinnvoll ist, eine Gucci Cap zu kaufen,
für quasi Real-Life-Status in seiner bekannten Gruppe?
Dass das irgendwie besser ist, als sich den Season Pass für Dark-Matter-Tarnung zu kaufen?
Wer legt das fest?
Letztendlich sollte es doch darum gehen, wo er für sich persönlich quasi die,
sag mal mal, wie soll man das nennen, die größere Erfüllung daraus hat.
Und wenn das bei allem der Dark-Matter-Skin ist, dann meinetwegen der Dark-Matter-Skin.
Und wenn der andere richtig krass da, ist das eine Gucci Cap?
Das sieht, guck mal, das sieht doch wirklich so aus.
Habt ihr das, was wollt ihr von mir?
Das sieht doch so aus.
Ja, okay, also wenn der Typ sich für 350 Euro eine Kappe, oder für 300 Euro eine Kappe kaufen kann,
dann hat er, glaube ich, auch keine Probleme, sich den aktuellen Season Pass zu leisten.
Gut, mal ehrlich gesagt, er hat es wahrscheinlich nicht gekauft,
seine Eltern haben es wahrscheinlich gekauft.
Jaja, das habe ich ja schon gesagt.
Das sehe ich generell bei Spielen auch als Problem.
Und es gibt ja nicht umsonst genug Länder, die sagen,
hey, diese klassische Lootbox-Mechanik wollen sie nicht mehr dulden.
Mein Problem damit ist hauptsächlich, dass die Spiele dadurch schlechter werden.
Und ich irgendwie frech finde, dass Spielehersteller versuchen,
mittlerweile bei einem Vollpreisspiel, also dass es mittlerweile etabliert ist,
FIFA ist das beste Beispiel,
dass es mittlerweile schon bei manchen Marken oder bei immer mehr etabliert ist,
dass ein Vollpreisspiel die Leute 2, 3, 4, 5 Mal zur Kasse bittet.
Wenn schon mehr.
Mehr als 1.000 Euro bestimmt.
Und wobei gibt man da so viel Geld aus?
Also bei manchen Spielen kauft man sich halt mit dem Geld so Charakter-Skins.
Die haben sich da aber auch genau die richtigen Kandidaten ausgesucht, oder?
Die haben sich da genau die richtigen...
Ich...
Die richtigen Leute zu diesem Beitrag ausgesucht.
Die so quasi...
Wenn jemand diesen Beitrag sieht,
stellt euch mal vor,
wenn sich jetzt Eltern, die eh schon quasi da Panik schieben,
Hilfe, mein Kind...
Ich verliere mein Kind an das Internet.
So.
Wenn die diesen Beitrag sehen,
dann...
Dann die drei halbstarken Gehocken gesehen,
plus das Gelaber von denen,
dann wird ja noch so ziemlich alles bestätigt, was die für Ängste haben.
Da haben sie sich auch wirklich die richtigen Spezialisten rausgesucht hier.
...und nicht so wie jeder andere.
Oder in FIFA zum Beispiel kaufe ich mir so FIFA-Packs.
Ja.
Und mit den Packs kann ich halt Karten ziehen, die richtig gut sind.
Dann habe ich ein besseres Team als die anderen.
Ja, genau.
Oder man verkauft es einfach.
Oder man verkauft es und kriegt...
FIFA-Packs ist auch der größte Shit überhaupt, oder?
All ihr Taschengeld haben sie in den letzten Jahren hier reingesteckt.
Ohne die Gucci-Cappe.
Ich finde es unmoralisch, Kinder und Jugendliche so abzufassen.
Darf man nicht vergessen, ey.
Die Kappe hat wahrscheinlich so viel gekostet wie 30 Packs.
Viele Spieleentwickler arbeiten offenbar mit einer Menge perfider Tricks.
Du Hund!
Du Hund?
Alter.
Er hat gewonnen.
Ich konfrontiere den Verband der deutschen Games-Branche mit dem Vorwurf.
Geschicht akkurat gedisst.
Digga.
Wir nehmen da auch sehr ernst.
Wir haben zum Beispiel mehrere Tochterunternehmen und Institutionen, die wir auch mitfinanzieren.
Das ist einmal die USK.
Die kümmert sich den ganzen Tag um Jugendschutz.
Und wir haben auch eine Institution, die heißt...
Die Stiftung Digitale Spielekultur.
Und die macht ganz viel im Bereich Pädagogik und Medienkompetenz.
Zum Schluss ist es ein Dreiklang.
Ist ja eine gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe.
Das heißt, gerade beim Thema Jugendschutz, da sind Unternehmen gefragt.
Da ist aber auch der Staat und die öffentlichen Institutionen gefragt.
Und als drittes natürlich die Eltern.
Die Gaming-Industrie verhält sich etwa so wie die Drogenmafia.
Sie schadet...
Der schreckt aber auch nicht davor zurück, immer die dicksten Geschütze aufzufahren, oder?
Da ist natürlich schon was dran.
Aber der kommt da immer mit Dingern um die Ecke, Alter.
... junge Menschen und profitiert davon.
Statt staatlicher Kontrolle Elternpflicht.
Doch viele scheinen überfordert.
Denn 50% der Eltern machen ihren Kindern keine zeitlichen Einschränkungen.
Und 33% beaufsichtigen die Inhaltung.
Das Problem, mal ganz im Ernst.
Zeitliche Einschränkungen.
Das Hauptproblem ist, wenn du solche...
Das kann ich jetzt...
Das kann ich jetzt nur von mir schlussfolgern.
Natürlich hatten wir auch Diskussionen.
Mit wie viel vorm Rechner und hin und her.
Und für, keine Ahnung, für eine gute Note in der Schule irgendwie da noch abends länger vorm Rechner.
Ich glaube, solche Sachen...
Ja, das hat jeder mal irgendwie gehabt.
Oder hat das immer noch.
So.
Zumindest das Problem an zeitlichen Einschränkungen ist,
ist ja eher, dass zeitliche Einschränkungen eigentlich hauptsächlich die Kreativität fördern,
wie man diese zeitlichen Einschränkungen umgehen kann.
Das heißt, du verwendest dann nicht etwa die Zeit dafür,
in Sicht der Eltern sinnvolle Dinge zu machen.
Du verwendest dann die Zeit eher darauf,
dir Gedanken zu machen,
ja, entweder was du machst, wenn du wieder an den Rechner kommst
und gammelst halt den ganzen Tag rum, bis du an den Rechner darfst.
Oder gehst zu irgendeinem Freund nach der Schule, wo ihr spielen darfst.
Sonst hast du also im Prinzip...
Die Kreativität wird dann darauf verwendet, zu gucken,
wie man das Ganze irgendwie umschiffen kann.
Natürlich finde ich es auch nicht sinnvoll,
wenn man jetzt sagt, okay,
ähm, was weiß ich,
Kind kommt von der Schule um 12,
was weiß ich, da geht man ja noch in die Grundschule,
kommt nicht von 12 von der Schule
und würde dann irgendwie bis 22 Uhr Fortnite spielen oder so.
Das fände ich auch nicht gerade sinnvoll.
Da muss ich sagen, das ist natürlich auch sicherlich nicht der Weisheitsletzter Schluss.
Naja, gucken wir mal weiter, was jetzt kommt.
Was schon der Buchtitel nach einer halben Stunde ist Schluss.
Ich sehe es jetzt nirgendwo, wo das steht,
aber in einer halben Stunde hast du ja heutzutage
noch nicht mal deinen Rechner und alle möglichen Clients gestartet.
Die mediale Kompetenz vieler Eltern ist schlecht,
sie können überhaupt gar nicht nachvollziehen...
Moment, das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht.
Wir haben gerade vom Spitzer gehört,
man braucht keine Medienkompetenz.
Man braucht Erfahrung in diesem Gebiet.
Medienkompetenz, Fake News,
das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
... was ihre Kinder da mit den Computerspielen, den sozialen...
Das hat damit alles nichts zu tun,
haben wir eben gerade gehört.
Michael, fünf Spieljahren, danke schön für den Sub.
... aus pädagogischer Sicht würden wir schon einfordern,
dass Eltern sich interessieren,
dass sie Grenzen setzen, altersgerecht auch immer neu...
Wichtig aus meiner Sicht ist,
dass die Eltern versuchen,
mal so ein bisschen dahinter zu steigen,
was da eigentlich abgeht.
Also sprich, dass man mal versucht,
halbwegs zu verstehen, was die Kinder da eigentlich machen.
Also wenn ich Kinder hätte,
und also gut, sagen wir mal,
ich hätte vor, als es noch angesagt war,
keine Ahnung, ich hätte irgendwie vor zehn Jahren,
wie gesagt, mit 37 ist das,
mit 27 wäre das kein Problem gewesen,
ich habe vor zehn Jahren Kinder gekriegt,
und dann hätte ich gesehen, die hätten alle Snapchat am Start.
Ich habe bis heute nicht Snapchat verwendet,
aber ihr könnt von ausgehen, hätte ich Kinder, die Snapchat verwenden,
dann hätte ich mir das auch mal angeguckt.
Dann hätte ich gesagt, okay, was ist denn das?
Ich bin zwar hauptsächlich so Twitter-User,
aber ich gucke mir das wenigstens mal an.
Also das größte Problem daran ist ja quasi
eher so das Desinteresse an den Dingern,
was die Kinder machen.
Und dann muss man sich auch nicht wundern,
wenn man als Eltern nicht durchblickt,
was da eigentlich passiert.
Ausjustieren mit den eigenen Kindern.
Nicht nur limitieren, sondern verstehen,
was man verbietet.
Das würde ich auch sagen.
Das sind 360, Conor,
die sind aber oldschool hier.
Guck mal hier,
das ist ja mal
2005.
Also ich habe einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit,
der fällt mir jetzt eigentlich als Beispiel ganz gut ein,
der hat einen Sohn, der ist glaube ich acht,
und der spielt beispielsweise
auch gerne Minecraft.
In dem Alter.
Zehn ist der.
Ich glaube acht.
Vielleicht auch neun.
Und der spielt gerne Minecraft.
Und die spielen zusammen Minecraft.
Spielt der Vater
mit seinem Kind Minecraft.
Finde ich eigentlich das Beste,
was man machen kann.
Vermutlich ist es, wie immer,
ein Kompromiss zwischen beiden Extremen.
Ich warne besonders vor der Nutzung
der Kinder und Jugendlichen,
weil deren Gehirne eben noch im Entstehen sind.
Und deswegen, was wir da falsch machen,
Also, jetzt habt ihr es gehört,
der halbe Kopf ist leer.
und ist nicht mehr veränderbar.
Und das macht mir wirklich große Sorgen.
Grundsätzlich ist meine Haltung zum Videospielen
bei jungen Leuten erstmal,
dass wir optimistisch sein sollen,
dass wir die Vorteile, die das hat,
für Entwicklung, für Wohlbefinden
anerkennen, wertschätzen sollten,
bevor wir über die Probleme reden.
Ich hab echt die drei Spezialisten rausgesucht, ey.
Sag mal, haben die alle drei
so eine 300 Euro Gucci-Kappe auf?
Guck mal, das ist doch genau der gleiche Kram hier.
Und dann in der Mitte noch der Adidas Jogginganzug.
Beste.
Da haben sie sich echt Spezialisten für rausgesucht
für das Video.
Was ein Typ halt.
Na gut.
Der denkt halt in dem Alter, wenn man so ein bisschen
aggressiv rummacht, das wäre besonders männlich
und zieht die Mädels an oder so.
Und die Gucci-Kappe natürlich auch.
Oh Mann.
Jaja, also der Beitrag ist wieder
so ein typischer öffentlich-rechtlicher
Anti-Gamer-Beitrag
gewesen, der eigentlich
nichts anderes machen soll, wie die Zielgruppe
der Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, nämlich irgendwelche
40, 50
plusjährigen Eltern
oder vielleicht sogar Großeltern, die quasi Angst
um ihre Kinder haben, durch das böse Internet
und aktuelle Spiele, da darin
zu bestätigen.
Also das hat mich jetzt nicht
in irgendeiner
Art und Weise überzeugt.
Für so einen Mist bezahlt man Rundfunkgebühren.
Naja, man bezahlt Rundfunkgebühren auch für
sehr viel mehr Mist.
Es gibt durchaus sinnvolle Sachen im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen,
wo ich sage, hey, dafür kann man auch mal
Rundfunkgebühren
bezahlen.
Ich überleg grad was. Gibt's aber.
Aber ich guck
so wenig Fernsehen, ich guck eigentlich gar nichts mehr.
Ja,
doch, was ich
cool finde ist, was ich auf YouTube immer gucke,
ist
so Handwerksendungen, so
wie heißt denn das, so der letzte
Schuhmacher von
irgendeinem Stadt oder so.
Wie heißt das denn?
Bares für Rares ist teilweise,
ja, kann man jetzt auch angucken.
Ich hab vergessen, wie sagst du,
Handwerkskunst, genau.
Das guck ich
mir immer, ich glaub vom SWR,
ja, das guck ich mir
immer gern zum Einschlafen an.
SWR...
Das heißt ernsthaft SWR
Craftmanship? Ne, ich glaube
YouTube hat das mir grade übersetzt, oder?
Das guck ich mir gerne
zum Einschlafen an.
Da hast du dann irgendwelche Leute, die Fässer
bauen oder so, das find ich gut. Dafür geb ich auch
Gebühren aus. Aber dafür bezahl ich auch
Gebühren. Ah, die sind neu.
Die sind auf jeden Fall neu.
Die sind 16 zu 9, 1080p.
Die sind nicht vor 20 Jahren gedreht.
Vor 20 Jahren, da war Fernsehen teilweise
noch 4 zu 3.
Die machen schon durchaus sinnvolle
Sachen im öffentlich-rechtlichen.
Was ich halt, also meine Sache
mit dem Rundfunkbeitrag ist,
ich finde das sinnvoll, dass es öffentlich-rechtliche
Sender gibt und ich finde es gibt auch im öffentlich-rechtlichen
Programm
Sachen, wo ich sage,
ja, das ist cool,
da bezahl ich gerne für.
Was ich, was mir nicht gefällt beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen, ist, dass es so
unglaublich ausufernd ist.
Wir haben, was weiß ich,
35 verschiedene Radiosender,
30 Milliarden Dingern,
die gemacht werden. Zum größten Teil
werden die Beiträge eh dafür benutzt, um die
Rente zu bezahlen von den Leuten, die früher mal
beim öffentlich-rechtlichen gearbeitet haben.
Also, ich hätte
kein Problem damit,
Rundfunkgebühren zu bezahlen, aber man könnte
sich vielleicht mal überlegen,
ob man das nicht reduziert oder
zumindest, dass man sagt, hey, man
verschlankt das Programm etwas.
Weil da ist aus meiner Sicht schon
unglaublich viel Überflüssiges dabei.
Natürlich, ja, du hast
das Problem, dass das
natürlich nicht nur ich
entscheiden kann. Was ich überflüssig
finde, finden andere sinnvoll, aber
es gibt schon
richtig viel Stuss.
Musikantendampfer oder sowas
zum Beispiel.
Das braucht, glaube ich,
keiner.
Oder irgendwelche
drittklassigen Comedy-Sendungen, die
mega unlustig sind.
Und 35 Radiosender braucht
auch keiner.
Du brauchst nicht
einen Schlager-Radiosender
im Norden, in der Mitte, im Süden,
im Osten und im Westen ein.
Die können auch ruhig ein Radiosender
machen für Schlager, wenn das so sein muss.
Also, da gibt es sicherlich
auch, wenn man sich alles
der Vielfalt halber anguckt,
einiges, wo man sagen könnte,
okay, das ist doppelt gemoppelt und das braucht man
eigentlich nicht. So, schauen wir mal.
Was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Okay, wir lassen uns
von LevelCap jibänen.
Eine Sekunde
von LevelCap jibänen lassen.
Ich darf dazu leider nichts
sagen, weil ich muss mittlerweile wieder
eine NEA unterschreiben, da ich nichts sage.
Deswegen ist es aber,
LevelCap weiß schon Bescheid.
Aber ich kann euch so viel
sagen, lang dauert es nicht mehr.
Und ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt,
was uns die nächsten Wochen bringen.
Zumal das Datum ja mittlerweile offiziell ist.
Ich darf's.
By the way.
Ich glaub, das darf ich wenn.
Ich darf's vorher schon spielen.
Aber, aber.
Aber.
Ja, AliExpress lohnt sich immer noch. Ich habe erst vor zwei Tagen wieder was bestellt, das was wir uns hier im Stream zusammengeklickt haben.
Und meine RGB-LED-Hausnummern sind auch mittlerweile da, komplett ohne Zoll und alles. Hat sich gelohnt.
Und falls das jemand jetzt zum ersten Mal hört, ja, ich habe mir Hausnummern gekauft, in die man RGB-LED-Streifen reinmachen kann.
Nein, die Nummern habe ich noch nicht angebracht.
Die Nummern basteln wir.
Die Nummern basteln wir im Stream zusammen.
Das waren deutsche... Jaja, du kannst in Battlefield 2042, gibt es so einen Custom-Mode, also gibt es so einen Modus-Designer, wo du die Assets drin hast von Battlefield 3, Battlefield 1942 und...
Was war das andere? Battlefield 3, BC2, BC2, BF3 und 1942.
Da kannst du so Custom-Spielmodi zusammenbauen, wo du dann beispielsweise auch mit den Uniformen...
...rumläufst, ja.
Achso! Die ist 22 Jahre da, ich wollte gerade sagen, die sieht nicht aus wie 22.
Verdunski.
Ja, sieh an.
Die Gäste und die Stadion- und Untergründepflege sind durch einen Untergrundbombing verletzt.
Die Bunker auf der Reihe auf dem Map haben einen Overhaul-Thema von World War 2 und die original GULAG ist wieder am Rennen.
Das Halloween-Warzone-Event wird auch am 19.
Überall ist das eine ziemlich große Anwendung für die Integration in die Cold War mit der Warzone.
Call of Duty Vanguard wird mit dem Battle Royale nach dem Launch integriert und bringt ein ganz neues Map mit.
Ich muss euch sagen, Vanguard...
ist das, also mich haben ja die letzten Call of Duties nicht mehr großartig geschockt,
aber Vanguard schockt mich absolut gar nicht.
Das Spiel interessiert mich komplett null.
Minus, minus eins interessiert mich Vanguard.
Aber dieses Game ist ja nie rausgekommen.
Das wollte er ja machen und dann hat Konami keinen Bock mehr gehabt
und dann hat er Death Stranding gemacht.
Hast du die Hausnummer bestellt? Ja, bei AliExpress.
Das scheint unwahrscheinlich zu sein.
Konami hat letztens eine totale Restrukturierung ihres Gaming-Businesses eröffnet
und wir werden wahrscheinlich neue Titel für nächstes Jahr eröffnen.
Insurgency Sandstorms Entwickler arbeiten auf Updates für das Konsoleport des Spiels.
Es hat vor dieser Woche zwei Rave-Reviews eröffnet,
aber es gibt ein paar Probleme mit dem Spiel, die müssen beantwortet werden.
Was heißt denn Rave-Reviews?
Ich würde das so interpretieren nach dem Motto, richtig gute Bewertung,
aber so ganz sicher bin ich mir da nicht, wie ich das übersetzen soll.
Was sind denn Rave-Reviews?
Rave-Reviews unter Drogen-Einfluss, ja genau, das wird es bestimmt sein.
Begeisterte Kritik, ah, verstehe.
Oh, das ist die Oldschool, das ist die richtig Oldschool-Aug gewesen,
wie es die früher in CS gab, mit dem Guckrohr.
Warte mal, war Aug jetzt österreichisch oder schweizerisch, ich glaube österreichisch, oder?
War das österreicher?
Österreich.
Ja, die China-Chinesen gehen wieder ab.
Mit History haben es die Chinesen eh nicht so,
weil da müsste man vielleicht auch ein paar Dinge ansprechen,
die auch gerade in der China-Chinesischen Historie
vielleicht nicht ganz so geil gewesen sind.
Das ist nicht so.
Das mögen die aber nicht.
Okay.
Du darfst weder gut noch evil sein, du darfst einfach nur für die Partei sein,
sonst darfst du nix in China wahrscheinlich.
Es gibt in China nicht gut oder böse.
Es gibt in China nur noch richtig oder falsch.
Richtig ist, wenn du das willst und das machst und das glaubst und das super findest,
was der Ober-China-Chinese sagt, und alles andere ist falsch.
Deswegen wird das jetzt gebannt.
Das ist natürlich auch eine gute Taktik.
Buying up studios.
They just acquired Demon's Souls Remake Studio Bluepoint Games
and have their sites set on other studios as well.
The biggest players in the game like Microsoft, Sony, Epic, Tencent and others
have been on a spending spree in the past two years,
gobbling up any studio looking for a buyout.
And while the acquisitions are tapering off this year,
it's clear the industry is consolidating around the major publishers.
EA have added four new titles to NVIDIA's GeForce Now game streaming service.
Dragon Age Inquisition,
Mirror's Edge Catalyst,
Battlefield 1,
and Unravel 2
are all available on any device supported by the service.
Technically, that means you can now play a full-on Battlefield game on your phone.
And while game streaming is still a relatively niche way of playing,
it's improved dramatically over the past few years.
Aside from bandwidth requirements and latency issues,
game streaming is now nearly indistinguishable from running it on local hardware.
Nein, wird's nicht sein.
Das...
Das sagen sie alle.
Jeder Game-Streamer ever sagt so,
nein, man merkt überhaupt keinen Unterschied,
ob es Game-Streaming ist oder lokal bei dir auf dem Gerät läuft.
Ich mach das zwei Sekunden an und sag, du hast Game-Streaming.
Also ich...
Das merkste.
Instant merk ich das.
... development around PC.
They're aiming for a 50-v-50 split of revenue between PC and console platforms.
That means their console-exclusive titles like Monster Hunter Rise will be getting PC releases.
It also means no more timed console exclusives in the future.
Apparently they're changing things up thanks to record sales of Resident Evil and the PC release of Monster Hunter.
Ich glaube, ohne Scheiß, das aktuelle Resident Evil,
ich glaube, das war wirklich eines der gefundensten Fressen für Rule 34 im Internet.
Ich glaube, die Leute, also die sind ja da schon, die sind ja auf große, große Vampirfrau,
sind die ja schon, als der erste Trailer am Start war, sind die ja alle da drauf gesprungen, ja.
... Monster Hunter.
Ich glaube, das war wirklich ein gefundenes Fressen fürs Internet.
Die neueste Version des Halo-Infinites-Technik-Playtests ist ein massiver Verbesserung der letzten Builds.
Sie verbessert die Leistung auf allen Plattformen,
während sie endlich eine stabile 120-FPS-Erfahrung auf den nächsten-Gen-Consolen erzielt.
Der große Ausgleich hierbei ist PC,
der immer noch an akzeptablen Leistungs-Leveln zu funktionieren ist.
Der aktuelle Playtest läuft durch den Wochenende und bietet...
Also ich wollte mal wirklich erzählen, das Ding läuft mit 120 FPS auf der Konsole super,
hat aber Probleme, auf dem PC ordentlich zu laufen.
Daub das am Start hier, da habe ich so meine Zweifel dran.
X, genau.
Jawoll, schön Solo-Questen in einem MMO.
Das ist halt genau...
Das ist halt genau das andere Beispiel zu,
weil wir es vorhin von New World hatten.
Das ist halt genau der andere Ansatz.
Nur das ist, glaube ich, für die Leute,
die das mögen,
wirklich somit das Beste ist.
Und die werden halt in New World nicht glücklich.
Ehe so ist was für Singleplayer-Spieler,
die chatten wollen dabei.
Riesig, der Sleeper.
Aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen, vorher haben sie erstmal das GTA 4 Remake-Projekt von GitHub,
hart runtergestreikt.
...
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Timos Hardware-Haus.
Hab ich noch nie was von gehört.
Das ist schon ziemlich genau.
Und als ich den dort gesehen habe, dachte ich mir schon so, hm, der ist ja gar nicht so alt.
Und nee, das ist er tatsächlich nicht.
Ihr seht ja auch schon rechts unten den Intel-Aufkleber.
Der ist wirklich gar nicht so alt.
Und ich bin sehr gespannt, ob der PC noch funktioniert.
Und warum er eigentlich weggeworfen wurde.
Weil ich würde sowas lieber verkaufen, anstatt wegzuwerfen.
Mich würde interessieren, ob der Typ seine Festplatte vorher gelöscht hat oder ob er eine drin ist.
Bevor wir aber mit dem Video beginnen, würde ich mich nochmal ganz herzlich für die 2000 Abonnenten bedanken.
Das ist wirklich richtig, richtig krass.
Ich schaue mal, ob ich da irgendein Special oder so hinbekomme.
Mal gucken.
Aber wirklich vielen, vielen, vielen Dank.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
So, kommen wir auch schon zum PC.
Und ja, wie gesagt, ich habe hier das Ganze draußen gemacht, weil der PC wirklich super, super eklig und dreckig ist.
Echt? Das sieht gar nicht so dreckig aus?
Ich sehe, wenn ich den aufmache, weil ich habe schon mal oben so reingeguckt ein bisschen.
Und das sieht echt nicht so schön da drin aus.
Unten rechts sieht man auch einen Intel Core i3-Aufkleber.
Ja, schade, leider kein i5 oder i7.
Aber immerhin.
Zumindest wahrscheinlich ab vierter Generation.
Mal schauen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also für umsonst kann man das durchaus gefallen lassen.
Aber sehr interessant.
Was die Ports auf der Rückseite angeht.
Haben wir einmal PS2.
Das sieht doch alles relativ sauber aus.
VGA und HDMI.
Einmal LAN.
Die ganzen Audio-Ports und die Grafikkarte, wie man schon sieht.
Guck mal, der hat sogar schon...
Nee, das ist es.
HDMI und DVI.
Ja, aber ich kann sagen, Display-Port hast du.
Also es sieht jetzt...
Guck mal, das ist sogar eine doppelte Grafikkarte.
Das ist ganz so scheiße.
Kann das gar nicht sein, was da drin steckt?
Doppelslot-Grafikkarte.
Das heißt, die wird auch nicht so alt sein.
Und unten haben wir noch ein Standard-Netzteil, was ich jetzt nicht wirklich zuordnen kann.
Sogar einen optischen Ausgang.
Das Mainboard ist auch nicht der größte.
Ganz kurz, wie unglaublich eklig dieser PC einfach ist.
Das, was ihr hier jetzt seht, klebt tatsächlich.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist und ich will es auch gar nicht anfassen.
Das ist einmal hier, das ist auch auf der Oberseite und das ist echt nicht schön.
Aber wir machen den PC jetzt einfach mal auf und gucken mal, wie es innen aussieht.
Weil es sieht nicht sehr schön aus.
Die Seitenwand des PCs ist zum Glück mit zwei Schrauben befestigt, die man mit der Hand abdrehen kann.
Das ist sehr angenehm.
Und beim Aufschrauben zeigt sich auch schon...
Was ist denn das für ein Go?
Coolmaster.
Was auch echt schwer ist.
Wie man hier auch schon erkennen kann, sieht sehr schön aus.
Die Seitenwand des PCs ist mit zwei Schrauben befestigt, die man mit der Hand abdrehen kann.
Das ist sehr angenehm.
Und beim Aufschrauben zeigt sich auch schon...
Das ist bestimmt ein LC-Power-Schiena-Netzteil.
Ja, er ist wirklich ziemlich schlau.
Ne, das ist Silverstone.
Kein LC-Power-Schiena-Abfackeln-Netzteil.
Aber die Festplatte ist noch drin.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob da jetzt noch was drauf ist.
Die Kabel gehen auch wieder komplett innen rum.
Ich weiß nicht, Kabelmanagement gibt es anscheinend nicht.
Wobei ich sagen muss, das ist bei einem Gehäuse auch echt schwer.
Wie man hier auch schon erkennen kann, ist auch noch eine Festplatte im System verbaut.
Das Netzteil ist von Silverstone und hat oben komische Punkte drauf.
Es ist ebenfalls eine Zwei-Lüfter-Grafikkarte verbaut.
Ein Intel-Stockkühler, zwei RAM-Riegel, ein CD-Laufwerk und noch zwei Gehäuse-Lüfter.
Also mal gucken, was das wird.
Hier sieht man auch noch mal ganz kurz...
Sieht gar nicht mal so kacke aus.
...die Lüfter da schon wirklich viel Staub dran, auch an den Kabeln.
Ich bin mir sicher, das kann man alles reinigen.
Aber ob der PC noch funktioniert, das weiß ich nicht.
Es könnte tatsächlich sein, dass irgendwelche Komponenten schon Schaden genommen haben.
Aber ich hoffe einfach mal nicht.
Der geht.
Also ich könnte wetten so, dass das geht.
Das ist eine Toshiba-1TB-Festplatte.
Das heißt...
Das war noch nichts.
Das ist alles trocken.
Der SSD ist leider aber nicht verbaut.
Nur eine Festplatte.
Aber trotzdem cool.
Hier sieht man einmal das Silverstone-Netzteil.
Das hat wirklich komische Punkte obendrauf und ist auch sehr staubig.
Aber das muss nicht zwingend heißen, dass es kaputt ist.
Aber bei Netzteilen...
Ist das Netzteil falsch rum?
...würde ich sowieso immer etwas aufpassen.
Die Grafikkarte, wie sie sich rausstellt, ist eine Radeon R9 270.
Das heißt...
...gar nicht mal so...
...so alt, würde ich sagen.
Klar, schon etwas älter.
Aber mit der kann man heutzutage auch noch was machen.
Ist eine 2GB-Karte.
Und ja, ist natürlich, wie man hier auch schon erkennen kann, sehr staubig.
Aber mal gucken, ob wir das reinigen können.
Der Prozessor-Lüfter ist, wie man sieht, auch sehr mit Staub zugesetzt.
Aber das sollte man reinigen können.
Elf Jahre, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Der Kabel ist auf der Unterseite der Staubfilter.
Der ist wirklich komplett zugesetzt mit Staub, wie man hier mal kurz sehen kann.
Also...
Ja.
Der Staubfilter macht das, wofür er da ist.
Staubfilter.
Das ist wirklich ein Extrembeispiel.
Ich würde aber mal sagen, ich werde den PC später erst testen.
Ich werde erst mal alle Komponenten sauber machen und die neu zusammenbauen.
Da ich echt Angst habe, dass ich...
Ehrenfilter.
...irgendwas kaputt mache.
Staubfilter-MVP.
Deswegen werde ich jetzt erst mal alle Komponenten aus dem PC rausbauen.
Der Staubfilter macht das, was er soll.
Und die Komponenten mal vorstellen.
Also, was was ist.
Und danach werde ich den PC wieder zusammenbauen.
Und dann werden wir ihn testen, ob er noch funktioniert.
Angefangen hier mit der Radeon R9 270 von PowerColor.
Die sieht eigentlich noch ziemlich gut intakt aus.
Und hier seht ihr die mal einmal ganz kurz.
Also, sieht noch sehr gut aus.
Sieht sehr schick aus, ist aber natürlich sehr staubig.
Aber das kann man ja reinigen.
Als ich aber die Rückseite der Karte gesehen habe, habe ich mir schon ein bisschen Sorgen gemacht.
Weil das war nicht nur Dreck, das war auch feucht.
Und das ist natürlich dann nicht so gut.
Klar, wenn die Grafikkarte nicht so betrieben wird, an Strom angeschlossen wird, sollte das noch okay sein.
Aber ich hoffe mal, ich kriege das überhaupt gereinigt.
Weil das war schon wirklich sehr festgesetzter Staub.
Als nächstes habe ich mich dem Mainboard gewidmet.
Das ist übrigens ein ASRock W85M Pro 4.
ASRock!
Für den Sockel 1150.
Jawoll!
Das Rausbauen hat etwas gedauert.
Weil wegen den ganzen Kabeln.
Aber am Ende seht ihr das mal ganz kurz hier.
Ist wie gesagt auch sehr staubig.
Aber sieht trotzdem noch ziemlich gut aus.
Das sieht alles allgemein, sieht jetzt alles noch ziemlich gut intakt aus.
Das sind zwei Crucial RAM Riegel mit jeweils 4 GB DDR3.
Sprich, wir haben 8 GB RAM.
Geht doch eigentlich.
Da kannst du sogar Windows 11 drauf laufen lassen.
Was eigentlich auch ganz okay ist.
Beim Abnehmen des CPU Kühlers und Reinigen der wirklich vertrockneten Wärmeleitpaste
zeigt sich ein Intel Core i3-4150.
Ja, ist eine Einsteiger.
Core i3-CPU der vierten Generation.
Wie gesagt, leider kein i5.
Aber trotzdem für einen weggeworfenen PC doch ganz okay.
Ja, jetzt kommen wir zum Teil, der mich echt auch ein bisschen angewidert hat.
Und zwar das Gehäuse bzw. die restlichen Komponenten daraus bauen.
Sind halt Fussel.
Weil wie man hier auch mal ganz kurz sieht.
Einmal, einmal den Sauger genommen und gesaugt.
Hier sind wirklich Staubklumpen hinten drin von der Größe.
Die habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen vorher.
Also das ist wirklich schon sehr, sehr extrem.
Und Notschutz aufziehen.
Der Rutsch vor der Festplatte war wirklich ziemlich einfach.
Und hier noch mal kurz.
Das ist eine Toshiba 1 TB Festplatte.
Mit 7200 RPM.
Also eine ganz normale...
Die SSD, die da...
Da war bestimmt ursprünglich eine SSD drin.
Die hat der Typ ausgebaut und in einen neuen Rechner gepackt.
Desktop, 1 TB Festplatte.
Sehr gut.
Aber wie gesagt, leider ohne SSD im System.
Als ich die Vorderwand des Gehäuses abgenommen habe,
habe ich erst mal diesen unglaublichen Staub gesehen,
der sich da angesammelt hat an den Lüftern.
Das war ja wirklich komplett zugesetzt.
Aber zum Glück kann man das reinigen.
Es ist nur sehr eklig.
Es ist halt ein...
Nach dem Ausbau des Netzteils...
Es ist halt ein Staubfilter.
Der filtert halt ein paar Jahre und dann sieht er so aus.
Und drunter...
Das ist jetzt alles auseinander gebaut.
Ich habe alles hier mal auf den Tisch ausgebreitet.
Und ich werde jetzt anfangen, das einzeln sauber zu machen.
Und dann werde ich auch wieder reingehen
und dann den PC wieder zusammenbauen und testen.
Bei der Grafikkarte habe ich erst angefangen,
die Schutzkappe für den Crossfire-Connector abzumachen.
Dann habe ich die vier Schrauben gelöst.
Und dann konnte man die Grafikkarte auch schon relativ einfach auseinander nehmen.
Als nächstes habe ich die Wärmeleitpaste bei der Grafikkarte abgewischt.
Okay, beim Putzen müssen wir jetzt nicht zu gucken.
Ah ne, das geht gar nicht lang.
Es gibt bloß eine halbe Minute.
Ich habe dann auch noch alle anderen Komponenten gereinigt.
Mit verschiedenen...
...Mitteln, auch mit ein bisschen Druckluft.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht alles aufgenommen.
Deswegen skippen wir jetzt direkt nach innen.
Und ich stelle euch alle Komponenten mal vor, wie sie komplett gereinigt sind.
Ja, ich habe hier alle Komponenten einfach mal auf den Tisch gelegt.
Und ich bin mit dem Endergebnis echt zufrieden,
wenn man mal bedenkt, wie unglaublich dreckig das Ganze war.
Besonders die Grafikkarte ist wirklich sehr, sehr sauber.
Das sieht ja schon wieder wie geleckt aus.
Auch das Mainboard kann sich sehen lassen.
Es sieht wirklich wieder sehr, sehr gut aus.
Ich habe wirklich darauf geachtet, dass ich den meisten Staub da wegbekomme.
Beim Netzteil habe ich leider diese Punkte,
die da oben drauf waren, nicht wirklich wegbekommen.
Ich habe es zwar wirklich versucht, aber es ging einfach nicht.
Nee, das ist kein Schimmel.
Wahrscheinlich ist einfach hier oben die Farbe irgendwie...
Und bevor wir das Ganze zusammenbauen,
werde ich trotzdem mal das Netzteil erstmal an den Power-Supply-Tester anschließen,
weil ich will wirklich nicht, dass das Netzteil mir irgendwas kaputt macht,
weil, ganz ehrlich, das könnte wirklich sein,
dass das Netzteil leider kaputt ist, aber mal schauen.
Beim Anschließen an den Netzteil-Tester zeigt sich aber beim Anschalten,
ja, das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut.
Die Werte sind alle ganz okay.
Der Power-Supply-Tester, der meckert auch nicht rum.
Das heißt, das Netzteil werde ich jetzt erstmal so verbauen.
Anfang für den Zusammenbau werde ich jetzt erstmal die Vorderwand...
Erstmal, erstmal den Kärscher-Hochdruckreiniger geholt,
das Gehäuse ausgesprayt.
...bauen, dann kommt das DVD-Laufwerk rein,
was natürlich auch festgeschraubt wird.
Dann kommt das Netzteil rein, was ich jetzt, wie gesagt, einfach weiterverwende.
Wenn es dann irgendwann nicht mehr funktioniert, baue ich halt ein anderes ein.
Und als nächstes kommt das Mainboard.
Hierzu tue ich aber erst die CPU in den Sockel,
tue Wärmeladpaste drauf, installiere den CPU-Kühler
und baue das Ganze in das Gehäuse und schraube es natürlich auch fest.
Als nächstes kommen die 2x4 GB von Crucial in die RAM-Slots rein
und dann wird die Festplatte verbaut, die übrigens die Schrauben zur Befestigung unten hat,
beziehungsweise das Gestell, in dem die Festplatte drin sitzt.
Das ist eine komische...
Ja, tatsächlich war es das jetzt erstmal so.
Normalerweise hängt ja hier noch sowas, aber da ist alles raus.
Ich meine, das hier musst du rausmachen, wenn du so eine super-mega-ultralange Grafikkarte hast.
Vor der Komponenten her natürlich fehlt die Grafikkarte noch.
Das Problem ist jetzt, jetzt muss ich das ganze Kabel managen
und das ist bei dem Gehäuse echt, echt schwer, ob ihr es glaubt oder nicht.
Ach was, Kabelmanagement.
Wer braucht Kabelmanagement? Einfach reinstopfen, zumachen und nie wieder angucken.
Hier, ja, es sieht eigentlich echt nicht gut aus, ich weiß, aber...
Ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
...es ist wirklich mega schwer, weil hinten null Platz ist bei diesem Gehäuse.
Auch, weil da so eine kleine Wölbung ist, das geht wirklich nicht.
Und die Anschlüsse des Mainboards und beziehungsweise die Löcher des Gehäuses...
...sind einfach reinstecken, zu machen.
Aber ja...
...sind einfach reinstecken, zu machen und nie wieder angucken.
...sind einfach reinstecken, zu machen.
Ich werde jetzt noch die Grafikkarte reinbauen und dann die Seitenwand hinten drauf machen...
Erox, danke schön für den Sub.
...und dann sieht das Ganze hoffentlich auch schon etwas besser aus.
Bevor ich allerdings die Grafikkarte reinbaue, muss ich natürlich auch hier Wärmeleitpaste auftragen
und natürlich den Lüfter beziehungsweise den Kühler wieder drauf tun.
Ja, das ist jetzt mein finales Endergebnis.
Ich habe auch die Seitenwand hinten drauf getan und die Grafikkarte ist auch drin.
Es sieht schon nicht mehr ganz so schlimm aus.
Natürlich die Kabel links, besonders der Lüfter links,
der hat ein Kabel, was genau dort auf dem Mainboard auch angeschlossen werden muss.
Das heißt, ich habe das jetzt unter der Grafikkarte hergeführt.
Das gleiche gilt auch für das Audiokabel.
Das ist jetzt so vorne links bei dieser Lücke.
Bei der Grafikkarte geht das unten durch.
Ja, die Karte hängt irgendwie ein bisschen runter hier hinten.
Das könnte vielleicht sein, dass es hinten im PCI-Express-Slot,
dieses Einrast-Ding nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Ja, die Karte hängt ein bisschen runter.
...ein bisschen umständlich gemacht, aber es sieht nicht mehr so schlimm aus.
Außerdem, Leute, der PC hat eine Seitenwand, wo man nicht durchgucken kann.
Also beschwere ich mich nicht.
Mach zu und mach an!
Als letztes noch die Seitenwand drauf.
Ich muss den nie wieder angucken hier drinnen.
Und schon ist der PC theoretisch gesehen betriebsklar.
Der geht.
Ich habe ihn ja noch nicht getestet.
Jetzt kommt der große Moment.
Der geht.
Was würdest du sonst nicht zeigen?
Ja, der Rechner geht an und tatsächlich kommt auch ein Bild.
Das hat mich schon wirklich sehr gefreut, weil ganz ehrlich,
der Rechner hätte auch ganz gut gar nicht mehr funktionieren können.
So nass und dreckig, wie der war.
Und gestartet hat dann tatsächlich Windows 10 und das hat auch ziemlich lang gebraucht.
Moment!
Der hat seine Betriebssystemplatte da drin gelassen.
Alter!
Ich habe gedacht, das war eine SSD.
Die hat der alte Besitzer rausgeschmissen und das alte drin gelassen.
Okay, dann doch nicht.
Richtig Pepega-Typ wieder.
Also der alte Besitzer.
Was normalerweise kommt, wenn man Hardware umändert und dann versucht wieder zu starten.
Aber nach einer Zeit waren wir tatsächlich im Windows drin.
Es war auch kein Kennwort mehr drin.
Also ja, ich habe das Ganze mal zensiert, weil voller Daten natürlich noch.
Oh Gott, die Leute sind so blöd.
Dass ich das gleich direkt zurücksetzen werde.
Und da werde ich dann Windows 10 wieder neu drauf installieren.
Aber ja, der Rechner funktioniert.
Ich oute mich jetzt einfach mal.
Ich würde es nicht gleich zurücksetzen, sondern erst mal gucken, was der Typ da so drauf hat, weil ich neugierig bin.
Ich habe natürlich mein USB-Stick geschnappt, habe Windows 10 installiert.
Das hat auch ohne Probleme funktioniert.
Und am Ende waren wir dann hier auf dem Desktop ganz frisch installiert.
Natürlich, wie man hier sehen kann, auch ohne Grafiktreiber.
Und die werde ich jetzt mal installieren.
Und so sieht das Ganze mit Grafiktreiber aus.
Ich habe jetzt noch ein schönes Hintergrundbild reingetan.
Hier sieht man noch mal kurz, was genau verbaut ist.
Wie gesagt, ein Intel Core i3-4150 mit 3,5 GHz, 8 GB RAM, eine R9 270.
Also auf der Straße gefunden, kann man das nehmen.
Also ich jetzt definitiv nicht mitgenommen.
Ich habe eh schon so viel alten Shit hier rumliegen.
Aber wenn man einen Rechner braucht, warum nicht?
Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Der Rechner ist ja drin.
Und ja, der Rechner ist jetzt fertig.
Also ich hätte es nicht mitgenommen.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, warum man sowas wegschmeißen würde.
Klar, ich kann es verstehen, weil es irgendwo lange rumstand, weil es total versifft ist.
Es irgendwie loswerden will.
Aber dann kann man es doch auch theoretisch für wenig Geld auf Kleinanzeigen stellen oder so.
Aber klar, für mich...
Ne, das wäre mir den Stress nicht wert, mit was letzte Preisleuten da zu reden.
Ich würde das wahrscheinlich aufs Dachboden stellen, so wie ich es, wenn ich neue Rechner kaufe, mit dem aktuell auch machen werde.
Für mich ist das natürlich jetzt ein guter Fund.
Und ich habe jetzt einen schönen Punkt gemacht.
Und ich habe jetzt einen schönen, funktionellen PC, mit dem ich irgendwas machen kann, vielleicht auch verkaufen.
Der PC sieht wirklich wieder sehr gut aus.
Und schreibt mir doch mal in die Kommentare, würdet ihr den PC einfach so entsorgen?
Ich nicht, auf jeden Fall.
Ja.
Achso, ne, entsorgen nicht.
Aber ich würde ihn nicht mitnehmen.
Falls es euch gefallen hat, würde ich mich sehr gerne über eine Bewertung oder ein Abo freuen.
Und dann würde ich sagen, bis zum nächsten Video.
Tschüss.
Bist du dieser 40er?
Ich bin nicht 40.
Alles, next.
Leute, eigentlich müsste ich jetzt mal was futtern.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Ich bin schon 3 Stunden 12 on.
Und nachher muss ich mit dem Fabian.
Spielen wir weiter Diablo 2.
Aber ohne Stream.
Kennst du das?
Ja, das kenne ich.
Irgendwas Spannendes, was wir gucken.
Ich bookmark mir das jetzt einfach.
Bam.
Bookmark.
Session.
New Folder.
03102021.
Save.
Yep.
Wann kommt denn das Video mit dem ehemaligen Azubi?
Naja, ihr hättet es euch wahrscheinlich schon denken können.
Ich habe ja gesagt, ich muss das Video am Wochenende noch schneiden.
Was meint ihr, Chat?
Habe ich das Video gestern geschnitten?
Nein, habe ich nicht gemacht.
Ich habe gestern den Heizchamp fertig gemacht.
Meine Heizung im Keller kann ich jetzt über meinen Home Assistant steuern.
Offstream habe ich das fertig programmiert.
Da war ich ein bisschen schneller.
Ja, wie?
Ja, ganz fertig ist es noch nicht.
Ist der Frasier eigentlich on?
Da ist er.
Oh, ein Zuschauer.
Oh, ein Zuschauer für irgendwelche Weep-Games.
Der Fabian mit seinen Weep-Games.
Weiß nicht, ob ich ihn hoste.
Das letzte Mal hat er sich beschwert, dass ich ihn gehostet habe.
Komm, wir hosten den Fabian.
Auf geht's.
Ich raide ihn.
Leute, wir sehen uns.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Und ich kaufe mir keine Gucci Cap.
Könnt ihr mal bei ihm vorbeigucken.
Ein paar sinnlose Emotes spammen.
Und wenn Weep-Games nichts für euch sind, euch dann was anderes suchen.
Also.
Ich futter jetzt China-Ente.
Mit Erdnuss-Soße.
Jutsch.
Ich habe nämlich extra doppelte Portionen bestellt.
Weil ich noch eine übrig habe.
Also, bis denn.
Macht's gut.
See you.
Ciao.